good morning welcome to the house
education committee um we will begin
this session with the uh Pledge of
Allegiance if we would all rise and
to the flag of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
all
I
you so just to begin with a few
announcements we have had trouble with
people in the audience hearing us but
they adjusted the mics this morning so
we may need to play around with them
bringing them closer or actually farther
away than we thought um so we will begin
with um House
Bill
1665 relative to establishing an
educator certification fund for PE fees
paid to the Department of Education um
the prime sponsor is not here so I call
on representative McDonald to introduce
the bill good morning representative
Valerie McDonald Rockingham 25 speaking
on behalf of the Prime sponsor
representative papovich Muller
Rockingham 17 this is House Bill
1655 relative to establishing an
educator certification fund for fees
paid to the Department of Education I'll
leave the presentation for director
representative McDonald can you fill out
a pink
pleas good morning chair uh fellow
Representatives um uh thank you for your
time this morning Steve applebe director
Department of Education um here for uh
House Bill
1655 um this is this bill the intent of
this bill is to bring how the funds that
the department collects for Teacher
licensing for educated credentialing to
bring that um how those funds are uh
transition from year to year into the
future uh in line with the fees for the
higher education commission uh the
higher education Commission in um
21n
8-a uh the higher ed commission there
specific language so that those funds do
not lapse they are other funds collected
for program review and used and then to
to review future programs in the higher
education world we would like to set up
the credential and funds the same way
currently today our accounting team at
the end of every fiscal year has to
ensure that they pull forward any
remaining funds into the new fiscal year
and if they miss an account or two which
sometimes happens um the the Bureau of
credentialing doesn't have access to
those funds for an entire fiscal year
easily so um this would continuously
appropriate them and make sure that they
don't lapse that's the purpose of this
bill the only question that we had on
our end again modeled it on 21 N8 that
uh lists the the the fees to the higher
education commission so we put down the
State Board in this
legislation it could be amended to say
the Department of Education if that's
cleaner so it could be either uh either
entity so to speak but the State Board
is the ru making Authority that can set
fees uh and credentialing standards
so happy to answer any questions thank
you very much are there any questions
yes representative Woodcock thank you
madam chair good morning good morning um
currently the fees are what for for U
criminal background check oh for a
criminal background check it's $100 okay
and that that
t yes followup thank you that may
typically go to the the paid by the
applicant um thank you it depends right
some some employers pay it I would say
it's probably 65 35 65% it's applicant
35% employer thank you thank you m thank
you any other
questions yes representative Cornell
Thank you thank you for taking my
question which would make it easier to
be administered by the State Board of
Education or the Department of Education
or does it make I'm told it makes no
difference irand thank
you representative Damon thank you
thanks for taking my question are the
funds non- lapsing
now they do not lapse but for I don't
understand all of State accounting
um I I not sure how many folks truly do
do yeah but but what happens is it's not
that they lapse they're there but we
can't always access
them and I'm not sure you know the ins
and outs the actual ual um uh
technically why but I'm told this
language means that our accounting folks
don't have to pull forward those funds
each year that they will automatically
flow into the next fiscal year I'll
followup and if I understood correctly
from your introduction there are
multiple funds so we have a higher ed
commission fund right that's already an
existing statute and then um we modeled
language based on that for the Bureau of
credentialing one
more
yes I think you said though that
sometimes some one of the existing maybe
they're not called funds oh I'm sorry
classes within a fund so in the state
accounting system there are accounting
units and then within those units there
are classes so there's a class for
full-time employees there's a class for
benefits there's a class for
um for part-time employees and so on
class for oit you know it projects uh
class for contractors there's all these
you know I don't know 10 and something
different classes and every one of those
has to be pulled forward each year thank
you any further questions for Mr applebe
representative Miler thank you madam
chair and thank you for being
here the use of these
fees do they help to pay for the staff
yes uh these fees thank you for the
question these fees are collected the
Bureau of cring receives no General fund
funding so these fees and and we do
re-evaluate them on a constant basis
these fees uh strictly go to pay for the
the actual work of processing educator
questions thank you very much and seeing
seeing no one else l signed up to speak
we will close the hearing on House Bill
1655 and have a break until 9:30 thank
you
everyone
right we will opening opening the
hearing on House Bill
1517 and I call on representative Noble
to introduce the
bill good morning everybody my name is
Kristen Noble I represent Hillsboro
District 2 the town of Bedford I am
introducing HB
1517 relative to the Statewide education
property tax and excess Revenue from
games of
chance will you take any
you we have one pink card and I so I
call on Mr Keen mang Juan from the New
Administration thank you for being here
you're welcome good morning members of
the committee my name is Keen M Wong tax
policy council with the New Hampshire
Department of Revenue the department
does not have a position on this uh on
this bill um however uh the department
did prepare a fiscal note and uh we're
just here to provide some observations
that we had uh so that the committee may
consider that during their deliberation
of this bill um
so
essentially uh reading of the reading of
the bill
tells us that the uh the intent of the
bill is to have the Dr when the Dr
normally calculates the uh the the the
amount of taxes to collect a 363 swep
amount a state education property tax
amount uh the department will need to
reduce that 363 by amount by this uh new
amount that's from uh the newly
established proposed established RSA 76
colon 3- a um and that statute the
proposed statute requires that the
amount uh to be collected from the uh
that's deposited into the education
uh where games where chips have no
monetary value um and then in games
where chips with monetary value is 10%
uh from the house winnings these are
deposited into the
ETF and then according to the proposed
bill um that amount anything in excess
of $6.6 million will then be used to
reduce the calculation of the 363
million
um
the effective date of this bill uh State
the state effective date of this bill is
July one of
2024 uh the Dr took this to mean that it
would impact the property taxes as
assessed on April 1 of
20125 um the concerns that the Dr has
with this bill is that uh it does not
clearly stipulate the date range for the
amount of payments that's been deposited
to the ETF that's to be used to deduct
the 363 million
so that's not clear to the Dr and also
um it's not clear how that amount will
be determined um probably we would think
that the best option would have would be
to have the uh treasury to provide that
number to the Dr so that we have a
specific number to use for that um for
any fiscal year to calculate the uh the
new um the new swep amount um we think
probably the best timing would be
sometime before September 1st um so that
we can perform our calculations and
provide the uh the necessary data for
Education as well because they need some
information from us to to feed into
their system to make their calculations
within a certain time
frame Y and I'll be happy to take any
questions thank you representative
drive thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question do you know
why they chose
$6,600 th000
as their Benchmark I'm not sure but
according to the bill it says it's the
amount that's estimated amount paid in
the State uh 2023 fiscal year so um I'm
I'm not sure um that might be through
the budget process that they obtained uh
the 6.6 million thank
you representative cascaden thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question uh just so it's clear in my
head I'm not sure I'm trying to
interpret this does this mean that there
is a cap of Revenue that would go into
the education trust fund at $363
million and then the balance would go
somewhere else
potentially um I the way we read this
bill I don't think there's a movement of
money essentially the money is in the
education trust fund from the uh the
collection from the games of chance um
however we're just it's it seems like a
mathematical change in the formula where
the amount that's access of $6.6 million
it's still in the ETF it's not like
that's going to be new money in um so
that anything in excess of $6.6 million
is going to be used to reduce the $363
million that we used to that's our
Target every year the $63 million to
calculate the the rate the tax rate to
get to the $63 million okay so that $363
million Target is going to be reduced by
that excess over $6.6 million it's not
that money is not going to be moved I
don't think that's any movement of money
from what I read in the bill um it's
just a change in the formula in the
calculation for the for the tax rate can
I follow it yes so does that um decrease
the amount in the education trust fund
based on that change uh I I would think
yes because uh this three without this
change the 363 million uh although we
don't collect that from the
municipalities they're still considered
revenue for the state and that will be
recorded as a revenue for the state so
now this will be reducing the 363 by
whatever amount that's going to be yeah
okay I got it thank
you question representative
belter thank you madam chair thank you
for your TCH support on this I just want
to run the way that I'm interpreting
this by you and see if you think this is
correct so they're estimating that um
games Jance gambling generated 6.6
million or will generate 6.6 million
from the 2023 fiscal year and what
they're saying it seems to me is that in
future years if Revenue people are
feeling really lucky and they exceed
that amount of revenue generated from
gambling then the amount of extra beyond
that 6.6 million directed to the
education trust fund would then be um
used to offset taxes from that would
otherwise come directly from taxation
into the trust fund is that basically
right yeah that's that's my
understanding as well thank
you representative
Damon thank you good morning thank you
for helping
us could you review what you said about
what the games of chance are and then I
have
a
so essentially this is a current
existing statute RSA 287 DD colon 20 uh
Roman 1 says in games of chance where
chips have no monetary
value 3% of all funds collected from
players uh less money used by the
Lottery Commission to fund authorized
Personnel expenses and related costs
shall be paid to the state treasurer and
deposit into the special fund uh so
that's a special fund that's created to
be to that deposit that that accepts
these these
monies um and then uh Roman two in games
of in games where chips have monetary
value 10% of that um will be
deposited yeah representative Damon
followup So
currently where are those funds being
deposited are they going into the
education trust fund but just not
relating to swept or they're going
somewhere else they're going to this
special fund RSA uh that's established
in RSA
2-j
um
and and it does go from what I read in
the in 284 DH uh the 284 col 21 DJ it is
still in the education trust fund it's
not going towards swep not that I know
of but currently it's it is deposited
into the education trust
fund one more follow thank
you and correct me if I'm wrong in
thinking that none of this relates to
the lottery money I I do not know I'm
questions thank you very much thank you
and seeing no more questions we will
1517 we will take a break until 10:15
hearing
all right we're going to go ahead and
get started and open the hearing on
House Bill
1311 the first card we have is
representative David pagee to introduce
his
bill
peternell good to see you all this
morning thank you for having us here to
legislation New Hampshire school
libraries offer students a window into a
world beyond their
backyard our kids encounter new ideas
that enrich their
lives contribute to their academic
achievement
and Foster empathy for those from whom
they
differ critically School libraries are
staffed by highly trained professionals
whose job it is to support each student
in collaboration with the students
family to find the just right books for
reading as we advocate for this freedom
to read bill HB
1311 we envision a future where these
sanctuaries continue empowering students
to explore ideas
freely including those ideas that May
challenge
them in the elementary school I attended
as a kid the library was the literal
heart of my school all of our classrooms
opened out into an enormous Central
Library space and I recall clearly as a
first grader during morning assembly
looking across the library each day at
the fifth
graders my path from first to fifth
grade was not just a progression through
the grades circled around the library
but also Jour a journey into and across
that Library where I could follow my own
curiosity encounter new worlds outside
my rural upbringing and develop a
learning in a state that values Freedom
attempts to restrict access to reading
materials have become a growing
concern New Hampshire is not unique in
experiencing a recent uptick in the
frequency of these
efforts we are seeing this phenomenon
across the United States encouraged and
embedded by the passage of state laws
that pose a direct threat to students
First Amendment
rights these laws designed for the
ostensible protection of children from
an imaginary
threat have had a measurable negative
effect on children's access to diverse
literature nationally more than half of
the materials that were targeted for
removal in
2023 were by or about people of color or
unsurprisingly these laws are currently
the subject of intense litigation in
multiple
States students regardless of their
gender identity race sexual orientation
or ability have the right to see
themselves represented in their school
library denying this fundamental right
HB
1311 is common sense bipartisan
legislation addressing this
issue it was developed in collaboration
with diverse education stakeholder
groups with direct experience including
the New Hampshire school library media
Association the primary goal of HB
1311 is to safeguard students freedom to
read
and ensure access to a diverse range of
free reading materials representing
multiple
viewpoints the bill prioritizes
non-discrimination while guaranteeing
due process for parents expressing
concern it offers a balanced and
practical approach rooted in
longstanding Road tested professional
best
practices
at the heart of the legislation is the
enactment of clear policies and
procedures which benefits all
stakeholders for school Personnel
responsible for material selection
adopting these policies ensures
decisions align to District goals and
reassure staff that they are working in
lock step with their school
leaders transparent processes for
addressing and resolving requests to
remove materials
directly meet the need of concerned
parents and
Guardians administrators in school board
members gain a clearer understanding of
how materials are selected and of their
defined role in handling materials
challenges ultimately the most important
beneficiaries are the
students whose First Amendment right to
access information is protected and
whose access to diverse perspectives is
upheld
HB 1311 mandates the districts adopt two
essential policies just two first a
collection development policy outlining
the criteria to be used in acquiring
Library materials the materials covered
include not only books but also ebooks
audiobooks library apps and other
Library
resources second the bill mandates
adoption of a reconsideration policy
which def finds the process and timeline
for addressing parent and guardian
requests to remove Library
materials these policies widely
recognized as best practice in school
librarianship are already in place in
most New Hampshire districts this bill
required the bill intentionally grants
significant flexibility to locally
elected School boards in crafting the
detail of these
policies such flexibility is crucial for
the Practical implementation of any
legislation in this
area different districts have different
experiences navigating materials
challenges and the bill acknowledges the
need for adaptable locally developed
processes and timelines this is
particularly important in districts
experiencing large numbers of
simultaneous materials challenges as
frequently while the bill delegates most
policy details to locally elected school
boards it does establish two
non-negotiable
requirements first policies must be in
substantial compliance with RSA 354
a27 which prohibits discrimination in
public education based on various
protected
classes this includes uring that schools
do not prescribe or remove materials
based on an author or subject's identity
within these
classes second district policies must
avoid Viewpoint based
discrimination this requirement flows
clearly from the US Supreme Court's
ruling in the Pico case which defined
the school library as a unique context
in which quote the regime of volunt
inquiry holds
sway in defining Viewpoint based
discrimination in school libraries the
court explicitly stated that school
boards may not seek to remove books in
seeking to prescribe what shall be
Orthodox in politics nationalism
religion or other matters of
opinion these two requirements are
fundamental and should be universally
agreed
upon HB
1311 is common sense bipartisan
legislation which helps us prevent
discrimination preserves local control
and guarantees concerned parents and
Guardians due
process it is rooted in a deep respect
for fundamental principles of free
expression and the diverse students and
families we
serve your support will ensure a
balanced approach that respects the
rights of all stakeholders Educators
students and
parents I appreciate your attention and
I would be happy to take any questions
thank
you thank you very much representative
Paige representative McDonald thank you
Madame chair and representative Paige
good morning good morning in your
presentation you mentioned the right to
representation in school libraries could
you please direct the committee to where
this is written in
law sure yep um it is part of having an
equal Educational Opportunity um which
is in this in the uh portion of Statute
that's referenced in the bill if I may
with a followup yes follow up um are the
words right to representation in school
libraries written in that statute if so
I'm not familiar with that they are not
explicitly written in the statute but I
would argue that it's an inherent coraly
of um equal opportunity thank
you
representative
belter thank you madam chair and thank
you rep Paige so it prohibits
essentially removing books based on
Viewpoint or Creed and Creed is simply
defined as a a series of uh beliefs or
opinions on a subject so it's very
broad so some things that qualify as
Creeds and viewpoints include Nazism
fascism communism chauvinism Cults
religions and
nationalism So based on this rule if it
were in place how would this apply to
attempts to remove the book mind comp or
Eugenics thank you for the
question I would humbly suggest that
many of those books including mine comp
which I'm sure everyone on this
committee agrees is a terrible work have
a have a purpose an educational purpose
in a school library they may reference
that book when they're doing a paper
about that period in time so when we say
that that book should be removed on the
basis of its Viewpoint we're actually
restricting uh our students ability to
understand and research our
history followup and if I may that leads
right into the the perfect follow-up is
at a foundation level
parents um because they are funding this
as taxpayers and they have the right to
direct their own children's operting so
why why should schools be required by
law to make a par to make available
materials that parents find
objectionable and that they are that
they say are subversive to their
foundational
values it's a fundamental principle of
libraries
as places of volunt AR
inquiry that everybody will find
something in the library they don't
like right you will find a book that you
do not like in the library I will find a
book that I do not like in the
library the purpose of the library is to
serve all of those different
students the job of the school librarian
the professional the trained
professional in that
building is to help each student working
with that student's family to find the
student if I may just one more last
questiones thank you because it comes to
the concept of voluntary inquiry which
makes sense in a general Library concept
but we're talking about schools so are
you saying that children are never
directed as a part of a class or by a
teacher or by anyone else with authority
over them in a school to to pursue
certain books or certain ideas in a
library those are two very different
things
so and this is this has been adjudicated
all the way up to the Supreme Court
there is the library is a space where a
student is pursuing their own path where
they are following their curiosity
reading what interests
them and that is uh that is where
government has no role in overstepping
and saying what that child can or cannot
do the parent does of that specific
child their own
child that is different from the
curriculum which is essentially
government speech right so those are two
different things you know if you're
saying what is the school curriculum and
how are they how are students directed
that is subject to a different legal
regime if you will than the library is a
questions representative
Miler thank you madam chair and thank
you for being here represent
paig in your development of this uh
proposed legislation I'm sure you had a
chance to talk with uh Librarians Etc
what's their biggest fear as a librarian
information I don't want to speak for
all librarians I'm sure different
Librarians may have different
perspectives um things that I hear
regularly are that students may lose uh
partic particularly marginalized
students may lose access to materials
that will help them navigate challenges
in their lives um and I'm thinking here
about lgbtq students uh students facing
sexual trauma um and violence um so
first and foremost I think Librarians as
educators are thinking about their their
students um something else that I think
is um on the minds of many
is the workforce itself and that lack of
clarity around these
issues um contributes to an environment
where all these stakeholders don't know
what is appropriate and not and that's
why policies and procedures are
important um it creates an environment
where parents lack clarity about whether
something is in Conformity with policy
and where Librarians worry if um their
administrators will have their back so
making sure everybody throughout this
ecosystem is on the same page help
school librarians focus on their job
which is serving students and it will
help reduce burnout and helpfully keep
keep school librarians and school
libraries we're having a real issue um
because of harassment that librarians
you're facing and and keeping folks in
the
leus one of the things I notice on here
is
age and so I am wondering if you think
that all materials are appropriate to
all
ages I don't think anybody would make
that
contention and I think that that is
where locally developed collection
development policies come into
play followup it's followup but it says
that they
can't um they can't prescribe materials
on the basis of the subject's age so if
they're told they can't then how can
they take appro take that into
consideration thank you for that
question that's an important point of
clarification when we're talking about
age there we're not referencing the age
of the reader
we are referencing the age of the
subject in the book or the author of the
book it's thank you
y further questions representative drag
thank you madam chairman thank you for
taking my question thank you um can we
talk about the the process of appeal
that you talked about would be like to
principal superintendent does it go
further than that to it to the State
Board of Education for example it does
it does not and allows the Local
District
to
um most of the details of that appeal
process would be determined by The Local
District and I think this relates to a
brief conversation we had in another
hearing recently um in that we're
talking about Community standards and
who is responsible for determining what
community standards are in my opinion
and I think the opinion of most that
should be defined by your locally
elected board because
they're the people of the community
they're the standards we're trying to
reflect um so that's that's my take on
that question is that it should belongs
within the district thank you follow and
I agree um that's what we're trying to
but I just wanted I think the idea is
that due process includes that step uh
for for parents that have a problem with
the the decision yeah and that yes and
that a standard best practice okay thank
you any further questions thank you
thank you very much representative Paige
thank
gerana thank you very much
representative peternell colleagues
Madam chairman Madam chair thank you
madam chair fellow Representatives uh
I'm going to take a slightly different
approach uh and speak to this
legislation from the perspective of a
professor at one of our public
institutions of higher
education it's important not only for
our young people to see their own life
experiences represented in the
literature that they read it's also
really important for them to be able to
see the lived experiences of people who
are not like them represented in the
things that they have access
to more than a third of our students at
Kean State College where I teach are
still first generation college students
we continue to have a a high percentage
each year with our incoming class of
first generation students a lot of them
come from small towns just as I did uh
when I went to college in the early 90s
and I'd like to say you know describe
for you very briefly a book that I read
when I was 15 years old book that there
have been innumerable efforts to ban in
public schools since it was first
published in 1940 and that is Richard
writes novel native son it's a
controversial book still for some it
repr reprs interracial sex sexual
violence systemic racism communism and
for all of these reasons there have been
over and over again uh attempts to
remove this book from not only Public
School curriculum but from public school
libraries uh this uh this book uh is
widely recognized as a classic of
American literature uh and it is a book
that meant a great deal to me as I was
just beginning to be exposed to ideas
that were very much outside the bubble
in which I grew up and I can tell you as
somebody who works with uh our College
age students here in New Hampshire every
day uh as someone who is taught at some
elite private institutions but is also
deeply committed to public liberal arts
education uh that a lot of her students
are coming from backgrounds that are
still in 2024 not dissimilar from the
background I came from uh I don't like
to say how long
ago having students prepared when they
enter the classroom and higher education
or when they enter the workforce after
that but obviously my area specifically
is is dealing with uh with college uh
having them begin to explore the lives
of people who are different from them
experiences of people who are different
uh than they are is a critical part of
the process uh especially in the high
school years of preparing you to be able
to go out into the world if you are
going to be a learner if you are going
to successfully be able to navigate and
to engage your wider World it doesn't
just happen overnight it is a process of
Engagement with new ideas and new
experiences that has to begin at a
younger age and our Librarians are
trained Professionals in understanding
Child Development and introducing
students to a apprpriate material as
they age through our school system and
then prepare to move out into the world
Beyond high school so uh I see this bill
as protecting policies that are for the
most part already in place protecting
local control these are policies that
are uh going to
be formulated at the local level parents
as well as Library professionals have an
opportunity to see all all of these
policies they are transparent they are
fair they are
Equitable and they're able to engage in
discussions within their Community about
the standards that they think ought to
be reflected in these uh in these
policies so I see this bill as something
that as I said protects what public
education should be about which is
preparing our students to engage in a
wider world but doing so in a way that
still allows these conversations to be
had between Library professionals and
students and parents policies to be
transparent fair and Equitable and
determined at the local
level thank you very much any questions
oh I'm sorry are you willing to take
questions I am thank you madam chair
thank you representative
beler thank you madam chair and thank
you for your testimony um I believe you
said you had been a professor can speak
from that perspective when you opened up
you you referenced uh the concept that
students need to hear stories that are
read stories that are different than
their experiences and involve people who
look different and are different and I
just wanted to ask is that is that a
reference sort of to the the idea of of
quote quote windows and doors uh which
is rooted in a standpoint epistemology
and critical or social constructivist
theory thank you for the question no
it's a reflection of my experience in
education thank you any further
questions thank you very much
representative ger thank you madam
Beerman thank you madam chairman good
morning um I am am here to give
testimony um opposing this
bill
um I am very concerned about the fact
that if a parent has a concerned about a
book that um we are taking in account
who the author is um instead of
concentrating more on the content and
the quality of the content in the book
um and when they're listing all of their
um criteria I see that there's no
mention of religion why are we leaving
religion out if we're going to put every
little aspect of a person's life
religion should be included in that
um and if we are going to start saying
that we need to have authors in all of
these different criterias then are we
going to start making quotas that a
school district has to have authors and
so many in each of these
criteria um I'm also concerned about um
RSA 571 obscene materials uh we were
told in another hearing that um if
there's obscene materials in a library
that we should be able to take them out
but if the author meets one of these
criteria are we not going to be able to
take the books out is that going to be
something that's going to make it
difficult for a parent to have that book
taken out um um another thing when we
were talking about HB 1419 about harmful
and obscene materials in the school
uh bill um we did say that we would have
a chance for the parents to actually um
go to the State Board of Education if
their local board was not um producing
results that they thought needed to
happen and in that testimony most of
them were talking about local control
and that these decisions should be made
locally I've looked up at my school
board policy and we already have school
policy on acquiring Library material
it's policy igl and JJ
L-R
so in one instance you're saying no we
can't have this bill because we need to
have local control but now we have this
other Bill saying we want to put all
these restrictions on and not leave it
up to local control very
confusing
um and as far as the Librarians um
they're not trained school psychologist
and
psychiatrists and they don't have the
knowledge in the background to be
prescribing what books a child should
have if that child has had trauma or any
other experience in their life um they
yeah they took one child development
class that does not qualify them as
being professionals and having any kind
of information that would give them the
right to say hey read this book and this
will make all your problems go
away um and
then I just am just against all of this
and most school librarians these days
are following the American Library
Association and I have a very big
concern about the person who's in charge
of it because she is a self-proclaimed
Marxist so she is not following um the
United States institution so that is my
concerns about this Bill thank you very
much any
questions representative
Woodcock thank you madam chair good
morning good morning thank you for being
here you I I just at a follow up you
made the comment um you're talking about
uh Librarians asking a youngster telling
us um I think he said take this book
I'll make your problems go away or read
this
book read this book it'll make your
problems go away y I don't I don't see
that that as um what public school
librarians doing that what I see is a
youngster coming in asking about a
subject area in the librarian providing
an opportunity for youngsters to explore
areas that the child has has um asked
about versus saying this is going to I'm
not they don't come in and work as a
therapist or a person of that nature or
counselor I I see it much differently
than that and so I just wondering how
you picked up that you thought that the
librarians might supersede their skill
level and try to be therapist when
youngsters are actually going there to
find information about
issues I have seen reports that say
otherwise that Librarians are
overstepping their boundaries and they
are taking on the role of social worker
psychologist and not just librarian and
that they are pushing an agenda
themselves okay thank you thank you mad
chair thank you representative Damon
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question which is a followup
to representative Woodcock y could you
tell us the source of those reports
please um articles that I've read from
other parents um And discussing with
them um about their situations in the
libraries where the Librarians have
overstepped their bounds I don't have
the articles in front of me I can try to
send them to
you thank you that would be one of the
things that Librarians would teach
students is to know their
sources representative
beler thank you madam chair thank you
for your testimony we've heard testimony
that this really significantly hinges on
a supreme court precedent on Independent
inquiry so it's important that students
be able to according to this access this
information if they so choose have you
ever
seen uh assignments directions or
advertising being done toward these
sorts of controversial books in
schools
I
I just saw a recent uh assignment given
to a student in Massachusetts from a
music teacher um and saying that they
had to
find uh
music libr uh Library uh music in the
library that had sexual content in it
it any further
would you consider Elvis Presley
sexually influential or whatever as
music his
words how do you separate El prly from
the
enti well my mother would have one
concept ofis
Presley um I that would have to go
through a screening process of what
people consider obscene sexual uh
material but that's not what this that's
not the music that this teacher was
looking for okay they were not going
back to Elvis Presley followup it would
yeah follow that's okay if
um teacher were ask them
to to look at U
OD or uh
sweet Emma The melal Who a new
orleanian are
um various other predominantly people of
color singers who have been religious or
sensual or just folk
singers how do you think that would
function from the library
standpoint um the assignment was
focusing on students looking up uh rape
and other um abusive sexual content I
that that's why the parents posted it
and we're very concerned about the
assignment and this was the seventh and
eighth
graders thank you yep any further
questions thank you very much M Peterman
thank
you um Barrett Christina from the New
Association thank you madam chair good
morning good morning members of the
committee bar christiner from the school
wordss Association uh we are in support
of House Bill
1331 um in October of
2023 um our school board members across
the state adopted the following
resolution guiding on hba's legislative
positions n hsba affirms the
qualifications of School District staff
to research and select appropriate
digital and printed material for schools
literary and curricular decision
curricular collections should offer
students information that provides a
balance of cultural views further
literary collection should represent
diverse points of view provide a Global
Perspective stimulate essential thinking
skills and meet the interest ability
learning styles and information needs uh
of the learning community so that's the
basis of nhba support for this bill as
nhba testified on uh representative
cordell's bill I forget the the bill
number it was a week or two ago um you
know we did not take a position on that
bill because we thought um it had um
some Merit nhsp fully supports um
requiring in statute School boards to
adopt reconsideration policies and adopt
policies relative to the um the
collection governing collection
development for for the district's
library media centers um our preference
over uh House Bill uh 1311 um over uh
representative cordell's bill was the
policy requirements um that were in
representative cordell's Bill really
listed out what the policy was supposed
to be there was no not much room for
local maneuvering developing or crafting
their own local policy it was very
restrictive in terms of dates and times
and 30 days and who reviews it first and
where it goes on you know on a second
step and and and whatnot which are are
those are fine Provisions if some
districts want to want to implement
those um but we feel that the provisions
of House Bill 1311 um give local
districts more flexibility recognizing
that Manchester may want to have a
different process cook may want to have
a different process um I'm aware that
there was um a hearing maybe two or
three months ago um in do um I you know
I I spoke with the superintendent in do
about the process that they used and the
process that they engaged and including
different voices from from across the
community and we think that the um the
provisions um in House Bill 1311 would
allow local school boards the
flexibility to do that again coming back
to sort of the local customs and local
values um that we've heard some
discussion about local Community Values
determining what's in their Library so
uh we already have some sample policies
on these topics um we have a sample
policy on um curriculum development um
uh parental objection to course
materials um Library selection and
adoption curriculum adoption um and
reconsideration of instruction materials
uh these policies have have not been
updated in a number of years um
primarily because they haven't had to
previously um but sort of given the the
the current tenor and some bills in this
legislature and bills across the country
and book challenges it's certainly on
our radar um you know whether or not a
bill passes um relative to this you know
we're going to be looking at our sample
policies and see what may needs to be
updated on them and perhaps get get the
voice of some school board members um
who are probably parents most school
board members or many school board
members are parents let's not forget
that fact as well too um media
Specialists superintendant and and
school board members to help sort of
Craft um a a policy that can help
parents navigate um their local school
board their local school district when
they want to challenge on whether it's a
a book in the library or or a course
material so
um with that I'm happy to answer any
questions any questions representative
cascaden thank you madam chair thank you
Barrett for taking my
question I'm having a hard time
distinguishing what this bill would do
um in terms of revising the policy so
maybe there's something particular to um
local communities or policies I'm
talking about as I worked with since
2011 and 12 is what they're dated JK igl
kec C kc- KC
k-r I mean those are all the last two
are
reconsideration right of materials as
you know and you pointed out would it
just update one of those policies or
what would it do different sure thank
you very much for the question
representative um while the policy while
the nhsb sample policy itself may not
need to necessarily be updated we would
probably revise you're probably familiar
with the- RS that we use the regulations
in addition to sample policies nhba also
provides sample regulations we
categorize those- R which are process
procedures more they read more like
administrative rules we would probably
do some research and again this
committee may remember when we had a
bill last year I provided maybe eight or
10 policies that local school districts
were using I forget what bill number
that was I don't know if Jen maybe still
has those on file not making more more
work for to pull those to pull those out
I'm not asking that but we would
probably provide some sort of guidance
to districts into creating the Review
Committee um maybe a guidance document
for the Review Committee should consider
these things the Review Committee should
you know look for these attributes um so
maybe not the policy per se but some
additional guidance to our to our school
boards in helping them navigate the
process of their policy or their or
their procedure thank
you representative beler thank you madam
chair and thank you for your testimony
you opened with um a position statement
stating that you affirmed the
qualifications of the local um Personnel
to make these decisions can you speak
more to What specifically confers to
them that qualification to make these
sure thank you very much representative
I do know that library media specialist
is a um a certification through the
Department of Education what that
entails without looking at the rule I
don't know but it is a certified
position with the Department of
Education thank
you I actually have a question
question certainly children do need to
be exposed to a wide variety of
experiences and ways of life and all all
kinds of different subject
matter is there any
material in your opinion that would ever
need to be removed from a school library
because it might be inappropriate for
any age any school AG child thank you
for the question representative I mean
could I imagine that absolutely um but
that's not necessarily my decision to
make which is why nhba would support a
robust um committee if you will made up
of parents made up of Educators I've
heard of some districts will bring in um
a child psychologist or a pediatrician
to make sure that it's age appropriate
or developmentally appropriate I'm
certainly aware of some challenges I
think in New Hampshire reaching back
anecdotally where a a book was was
challenged if you will and maybe a
middle school and and they went through
the process and they said yeah you know
what this probably shouldn't be read by
seventh or eighth graders but we'll
we'll move it to the high school library
so is there is there some material I
mean there's you know I mean yeah in the
abstract AB absolutely there are some
things that should probably not be hand
in the hands of kids and you know there
are some gross things that I'm sure all
of us can't imagine who would ever
publish that so I hope that answers your
question Madam chair yes I think I have
a followup to
that we've been shown
material
that has been I assume it's in schools I
have not seen physical proof that these
books are in school and when I am shown
these books I say I don't want to look
at
possible that our culture
has gone off the rails a little bit in
terms of what we think is appropriate
for I mean students thank you for the
question Madam chair I'm not in a
position to to answer that I I will say
you know is there something that is is
there material whether it's in schools
or not just take that out of the
hypothesis for a minute that every one
of us would look at and say yeah wow
that's disgusting or not appropriate
probably but the challenge that we're
going to run into which is why we think
a robust policy process is is necessary
and bringing in multiple views on a on a
Review Committee um when do had their
their their hearing on a a book that was
being challenged maybe three months or
so ago there were a couple parents that
that spoke in favor of removing that
book from the library there were also
parents that spoke in favor of keeping
the book in the library so you know what
what's the school board supposed to do
in that scenario they they listen to The
Experts and they you know and the do
school board chose to keep that in their
Library the governor Wentworth School
Board may may choose differently thank
you very much thank you very much any
further questions thank you madam chair
Hampshire
okay good morning Madam chair good to
see you this morning um my name is
Deborah H I am here on behalf of
American Federation of teachers New
Hampshire and our 3700 members across
the state and I'm here in support of HB
1311 um I'm here because I think this
strikes the right balance in recognizing
the interest of everyone involved in uh
having good policies in place for
collection development and for
reconsideration procedures for what goes
into our school libraries and what stays
in our school libraries it recognizes
that our local school boards need to
have clear policies that everyone
understands for these um for these areas
it recognizes that there are some
parents who may have concerns over
whether material that's in the school
library belongs there or belongs at a
certain age
it also recognizes that students do have
First Amendment
rights um You elucidated by the Supreme
Court to access a wide variety of ideas
and information through the materials in
their school library it's not enough to
say well they can have their parents
order it on Amazon or they can get from
the local library not every family can
afford to buy a lot of books not every
kid can get to another Library they
don't always have transportation the
local library may not be open uh hours
they can get to so the school library is
something they have a right to access
and they do have a right to access a
wide variety of materials importantly it
also keeps any challenged material
accessible until the chance process is
completed so you can't have Shadow
Banning of a law of materials like we
have seen in many other states around
the country uh it recognizes the
responsibility of school libraries to
serve the reading and informational
needs of all students not every book is
right for every student students go
there to pursue things they are curious
about interested
in and not every student has the same
interest or are wondering about the same
things but School libraries have to try
and meet the intellectual
curiosity of each student with something
in the collection passing this bill
keeps the decision making on collection
building and how to handle challenge
materials at the local level where it
belongs local school boards are the
closest and most responsive to the local
community whether it's appropriate or
not is based on local community
standards so building that that rich um
Committee of individuals to look at any
piece of um The Collection that's
being questioned you know building that
Committee of parents and and School uh
personnel and whatever other experts you
want to call them whether it's child
psychologist all of those people on the
committee to review um a challenged
material should be done on a local level
because that's going to be a different
answer perhaps in a small town like
permont than it's going to be in the
city of Manchester maybe it'll be the
same but those opinions could be very
different depending upon where you are
you don't want someone in this building
making that decision for the whole state
you don't want someone you know down on
Hall Street making that decision for the
whole state you want it done on a local
level most importantly this bill
provides local school boards with
important guard rails for their policies
that will keep them within the
boundaries of what the constitutional
rights of students are and what's uh
required under New Hampshire law as far
as not discriminating against students
that's important to remember they do
have a right to an equal education we
can't carb out groups of students uh and
exempt them from having equal
access for students to become
enthusiastic for readers and LIF
Learners they need access to a wide
variety of materials through their
school libraries they need stories where
they can see their own life experience
reflected so they don't feel like
they're strange broken or alone they
also need stories and non-fiction about
people in places totally different from
their experience so they can follow
their curiosity to new countries worlds
and universities we want to spark and
Inspire them and they need to be able to
explore as far as their mind will take
them in poll after poll in local C Grant
stayers have consist consistently said
they support and trust their local
neighborhood public schools to educate
their students and for these reasons we
say you ought to pass HP 1311 keep the
decision local and let's have policies
everyone can understand and participate
in if they have a question thank you
very much any
questions representative beler thank you
madam chair and thank you for your
testimony um we've heard in your
testimony and others that this is a very
important item for local control and
make sure that it stays at that
level but doesn't this actually do the
exact opposite by severely restricting
the ability of locals to make decisions
on any of the books that fall under any
one of these very many very broad
categories no it doesn't because they
have to have a clear policy that they
have passed
locally and except for violating
constitutional
protections
there is nothing that um crosses local
control here so yeah we we're not going
to give you permission to violate
constitutional
protections I don't think that should be
a
question if I may I followup because if
we're talking about constitutional
protections and if these things are
constitutionally protected then why do
them
well we have examples from many states
across the country where people need a
reminder that students do have a right
to access a wide variety of materials in
their Public School libraries so we want
to protect our students and also save
the P taxpayers of New Hampshire the
burden of numerous lawsuits over
this any further questions thank you
very
much I uh last speaker Megan Tuttle from
Hampshire good morning Madam chair
members of the House Education committee
uh Megan Tuttle representing NAA New
Hampshire president for any New
Hampshire representing about 17,000
Educators across the state much of what
I was going to say has already been said
so I will turn in written testimony um
but just a few points I just wanted to
make quickly if I could this for us
we're here obviously to express our
support for House Bill 1311 for us this
is really about local policies being set
that are clear with
a myriad of different stakeholders
involved in it and setting those
policies on what's going to be best for
the community um keeping it within well
the community um you know developing
those the material policies that best
fit their communities it's clearly late
out it's not vague um I could go on but
A lot's already been said so I will hand
in written testimony and I will take
question
thank you very much any
questions representative
Woodcock good morning morning good to
see you um someone brought up a minute
ago about the uh media specialist
interaction with youngsters uh I think
Mike alluded to something similar uh in
training do you know um Megan if in the
uh
certification uh for media Specialists
or in their Ms or in the training is
there any train there or any coursework
or any requirements that outlines what
the role or the mission of a media
specialist is in a school thank you for
the question um I don't have a
certification in Li uh media library
Specialists but knowing what you have to
go through for other certifications for
different areas in education um I'm
going to make a wild assumption that yes
they would have that thank thank you mad
chair thank you any further
questions thank you very much we have
Brennan thank you madam
chair um due to the weather and some
scheduling conflicts a couple of key
members were not able to give testimony
today and so I'd just like to summarize
a couple for
you the New Hampshire school library
media Association is in support of this
bill they represent Library personnel
and they are um supportive of this
adopting a collection development policy
it provides transparency regarding the
school district's vision for school
libraries policies are posted on School
District websites allowing community
members
access requiring that there be a
reconsideration policy in place still
allows for local control and developing
procedures that allow for requests for
reconsideration to be handled in a
consistent and transparent manner these
policies and procedures allow parents
and schools to work together to make
appropriate decisions that take into
consideration the needs of All
Families additionally mom's Rising um
McKenzie Nicholson is the New Hampshire
senior director of Mom's rising and
Mom's Rising knows moms they are in
support of HB 1311 and they would like
you to know that um
they are representing moms anyone who
has ever been a mom loved a mom had a
mom um they're really
proud very broad right but they want you
to know
that study after study poll after poll
shows that restrictions on books are
unpopular with moms and grandmothers
from all backgrounds grounds in fact 78%
of mom voters 76% of Women Voters say
that a few parents should not be able to
restrict books from school libraries and
deny other families their choices about
what books their children have access
to what moms do want are for schools to
be safe and inclusive and to Value
diversity for parents to be a partner in
their child's success and for educators
to be valued and respected teachers must
be allowed to teach our country's truths
good and bad and the values that got us
to where we are
today we want all youth regardless of
income disability race ethnicity
religion sexual orientation and gender
identity to be safe and included in
schools that prepare them to contribute
to and succeed in society moms Rising
New Hampshire is proud to support HB
1311 a critical Safeguard to ensure our
Public School libraries have the systems
in place that they need to continue
fostering learning environments that
encourage critical thinking empathy and
the development of well-rounded kids and
we urge you to stand with us against
hate and censorship we urge you to vote
all to pass on hb13 and just briefly I
am a co-sponsor of this bill and I thank
you for your respect in hearing this
bill um and I do hope that you will
support this bill it is a pragmatic
bipartisan solution to address con
concerns on all sides of this issue and
I hope that we can get strong bipartisan
support from this committee to send this
to the floor with an a to pass motion
thank you thank you very much do you
have written testimony from those
organizations thank you any
questions representative
belter thank you madam chair and thank
you for your testimony you've just
provided um written testimony on behalf
of an organization um in this testimony
the organization claimed to be speaking
on behalf of all
moms how did they come about the right
to speak on behalf of all moms was there
a vote
taken so mom's Rising is an on the
ground Grassroots organization that
represents thousands of moms and their
state thank you any further
questions and seeing seeing none we
I'm going to take a 10minute break and
then we will start the hearing on House
Bill
we're going to continue on with the uh
the next
bill uh which is HB
1166 adding an exemption from required
Civic competency
assessments and um uh I call on the
lad thank you very much representative
cordelli and members of the education
committee for the record my name is Rick
lad I come from hail New Hampshire
Grafton five I'm here today to introduce
HB
1166 this is a bill that deals with an
exception uh to the Statewide assessment
for those students which are
participants in the uh Civic Air Patrol
or the junior Rozi program which is
taught in some of our schools so I have
passed out a sheet for you that I'm
going to choose to read it because there
this is information from the Razzi
program I think would be very good for
you to hear and so I will go ahead if
copy
thank you there is an overarching
purpose for the requiring civic
education in New Hampshire's Public
Schools yes the United States
citizenship and immigration service
assessment which we give in the high
school is one way to measure student
competency But ultimately the rights and
responsibilities of citizens are best
demonstrated through applying Civic
understandings and being Civic leaders
in daily life I brought this bill
forward in effort to recognize that
student participation in programs such
as the junior Reserve training Corps
program and the Civil Air Patrol takes
Civ Civic learning a whole step further
than simply taking a one-time
assessment there are currently close to
2,000 Army jrc Junior Ry uh uh programs
Nationwide as well as a couple overseas
in countries such as Germany and Italy
with membership close to 300,000 members
separate programs exist that are
sponsored by the United States Navy Air
Force and Marines of course I'm talking
about the Army because that's my
affiliation Army uh most Jr RC programs
are scheduled to run a school's regular
curriculum counting as an elective for
students wishing to
participate all Associated materials for
course or courses to include books
uniforms etc etc are property of the US
government and there are no
out-of-pocket costs to
students the junior Ry program is a
citizenship and character development
program the program mission is to
motivate students become better citizens
to make them them successful no matter
what they pursue upon High School
graduation and as a side note when
you're in this type of program there's
no requirement that you go on into the
military it's one where most of the
students which are in this do never go
into the military they just taking it
because they're interested in the Civics
and the citizenship that expounds this
program is different from senior Razzi
their mission is to prepare future
military leaders there's two programs
here the senior roazzi program is one
where you go off and you're going into
the
military the
jrc program prepares students to be
citizens the jrc program at White
Mountains has consistently been run
ranked in an honor unit with distinction
and the color guard has ranked fourth in
the nation twice Whitefield isn't the
only honors program in the State located
in langon New Hampshire Fall Mountain
Regional High School annually sees about
50 students participating in their JC
program which has ranked an honor unit
with distinction for many years at White
Mountains Regional High School the jrc
program is an elective one period a day
students take can take just the
classroom course but they are encouraged
to get involved with extracurricular
teams and community activities as part
of the regular course work students
receive time management
leadership I can skip to the other side
here citizenship Land Navigation
Marksmanship health and physical fitness
training the program encourages courage
students to know the world beyond their
community and this is a quote from the
uh lieutenant Colonel up in um
Whitefield if you stay in the program
for 4 years according to Lieutenant
Colonel Daryl Gearhart students have the
opportunity to go to Washington DC DC
Gettysburg where history is brought
alive Philadelphia Battleship Cove in
Fall River Boston and walk the Bunker
Hill and aboard the USS Constitution New
York City and West Point so this is
integrated into the program the program
has an affiliation with Adam State
University in Colorado which allows the
students students to take courses in
history citizenship and Leadership for
credit the cost to students is
approximately $180 per course very
similar to our concurrent dual
enrollment though local fund Raiders are
often able to pay for the courses for
those students who complete at least two
years of JC and decide to go on to serve
in the military they enter at the higher
pay grade of e3 and for you for you that
are not familiar with it I'm sure are
represent Woodcock E1 is you go in as a
private E2 as a specialist or a Corporal
E3 you come in as a buck Sergeant so
they're coming in if they've had the two
years of the Razzi program they're able
to come in and go the direction of of an
NCO and of course there's also the OCS
program within the military which they
can take advantage
of um going on Fall Mountain has class
classes Monday through Friday 5 days a
week all the roazzi classes support the
school's core values the program mission
statement is to help young people to
become better citizens and emphasize the
Civics that strengthens local Community
State and nation in regard to the na New
Hampshire Civil Air Patrol program which
is very similar in many respects the
program program is located where I I am
at Woodsville High School youth uh in
that program are emphasizing the same
types of activities Civics leadership
Fitness and character and there is a a
map Associated you can see where those
uh programs are located in our state so
I will conclude by saying that the
students which come out of these
programs have the they're able to apply
those Civic skills it through a
different way and I I feel for them to
have to come back and take this
citizenship test after they have done
this working in our community doing
community service and taking courses
within the school through certified
instructors um I think they've
accomplish that what we're trying to do
through some kind of an assessment thank
you very much uh thank you uh chairman
lad questions represent
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your bill um my question relates to
um well put it this way I just finished
uh rereading Plato's Republic I don't
like Plato very much but he made a good
point when he talked about the necessity
of those tasks with protecting the
Republic to have the highest degree of
Civic knowledge and virtue so I'm I'm
trying to I guess I'm trying to
understand if we think it's a good thing
for the average student to be required
to take this test so we know they have
that knowledge isn't it at least equally
important that those in that position of
knowledge there's many ways of assessing
knowledge and I think if you look at
schools and when we went to the
Statewide assessment I can remember a
teacher coming before this committee
saying a test is not the only way you
measure student understanding concept
skills and knowledge it's through the
application of those and this is a
program where we see it we see it living
we see the students participating and
civically engaged uh understanding the
principles of our democracy and
respectful of that I think these
students deserve that opportunity
they're sacrificing already by taking
these courses uh I I don't think we have
to have a a a duplicate way of assessing
whether they've measured up to the those
few you know uh questions on the on the
citizenship test I'm not I'm not anti
that I'm just trying to say at this
point in time uh they are getting these
uh skills through their program that's
being offered in these locations and uh
I I think it's
duplicative thank you additional
represent miler
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
bringing this before US Representative
lad I do have a
concern and uh it's the
exception I mean you have other Pro this
obviously is a very good program no
question about that but you also have
other programs that are out there I mean
you've got the whole um governance a
student governance in schools there are
student body programs you get elected
you're involved in decision making
you're basically practicing what we want
uh young people to do as far as
governance goes You've Got The Scouting
program they're involved in this on an
ongoing basis you've got uh some um you
got the demolays for example for young
men you've got the rainbow girls for
girl for girls for young women that are
basically dealing with similar kinds of
issues as far as uh their citizenship
volunteering working in the community
Etc my concern is just taking this one
program as good as it is and not
recognizing other kinds of programs that
young people are involved in so I mean
where is this a slippery slope the you
exempt this one and then we go to
another one maybe we should just get rid
of the program allog together as far as
having to take the test but um that's my
concern about this is that you're not
recognizing other legitimate programs
students are daily practicing the Civics
that we're talking about how so where do
the other programs fit in to this
exception several months ago I attended
an award ceremony where we gave the
eagle scout award to a student or not a
student to an individual that's been in
The Scouting program and there are folks
there from all the military branches uh
and the veterans are also from this
state when we're talking about this
program right here this is a program
that's offered in the School in the
school it's a school oriented program uh
students get credit for gra going
through the rzi program therefore I see
the I see all the Merit in what you're
saying that all these programs are
wonderful programs where we engage
students in going Beyond and learning
how to volunteer and learning how to
work together and practicing the basic
principles of the society we live in
however this program right here is
offered within the conf of the school by
instructors that are certified and
working in the schools uh Lieutenant
Gearhart if you've talked with him up in
Whitefield uh that's a program which is
well respected in fact parents are
asking and wanting their kids to get
involved with it seeing it it is a
school program offered and there are the
parameters which are controlled by the
administration in that
building represent Tanner thank you and
thank you for taking this um I've talked
with a parent of of a y Jr um from Fall
Mountain who was just thrilled with the
course uh thrilled what it did for her
son who's now in the military now but my
concern I guess is the same as um
representative Myers's you know when we
we first talked about the Civics test it
was pointed out over and over and over
again that a a test that has 100
questions on it um that are that are
online that are specific really doesn't
do what we deep in our hearts I think on
this committee want and that is for
students to learn what it's like to be
an American citizen um and you know we
have we now have robust Civics courses
in schools in fact karge has been down
here several times working with new
Futures and um we have the model United
Nations uh as well as uh the student um
councils and and different uh areas that
they have and it's not just community
service but they're learning you know
how bills are drawn up they they come
and watch here the Future Farmers of
America the uh we've had them here at
the committee they do a robust course on
Civics um and even though they're
outside the school some schools actually
incorporate FFA courses within the
school so I guess my concern is the same
as representative Myers I I would
wholeheartedly agree with this and and
but at the same time I would use it as a
stepping stone to allow other groups
that are doing
Hands-On
comprehensive assessment uh to certify
people so that they wouldn't have to
take this test um would you agree to
that I agree that there are many ways to
assess students and I've never been an
absolute supporter the only way to
assess what we're doing in Civics and
government is through the citizenship
exam one of which we anytime we do
assess we need to have a a bank of
questions which rotates so that we don't
have the same questions asked the
students over and over and over uh I
went to an experience like that when I
took anthropology in college I thought I
had all the answers to the test and said
I don't have to buy the textbook I don't
have to do anything we got it down the
attorney house was the first year that
the professor ever changed the
test and and so and my wife sitting
beside me then my girlfriend at that
time said I gotcha and so um I I I think
there's um a lot of thought that was
it's going into our Civics programs
right now we have a task force looking
at that I'm not absolutely confirmed or
are sold that the citizen test we give
right now is an accurate accurate way to
assess what we're doing in Civics
education
is it aligned with our academic
standards is it aligned with what we do
in government is it aligned with what we
do in history uh I've never been shown
that it does uh but it is one of the
tools which we use it's used widely
throughout the country in many school
districts and States um I'm not
objecting to that however I think that
if we think that's going to be the end
all and we've got the solution to what
we're doing I I think we would be in a
false neighborhood we have to really
realize there's many different ways and
this particular situation right here
we're not talking about an
extracurricular activity such as FFA
I've worked with the FFA 4 and all that
um this program is done in school by the
school and and approved by the school
board so there is a difference here than
some of the other extracurricular which
we're talking about we don't give credit
for extracurricular activities but we do
give credit for those activities taught
in the classroom in the schools or those
alternative programs which have been
approved by Administration in the school
so I agree partially what you're saying
but I also believe that this is a little
bit different than some of the other
areas we've been we've been talking
about quickly please just that with the
learn everywhere program and uh Extended
Learning opportunities we do give credit
for those things now in the
schools was that a followup Yeah
question representative
Hall thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question when I first saw
this I guess I was wondering all right I
guess I'll ask the question um is there
do we think even though we agree I think
we both agree on alternative assessments
that the kids that are in this program
would pass the test and this is just a
waste of their time to make them sit
through the test or maybe they might not
pass the test even though they've gone
through this
experience one once again I'll respond
that
what is the true
purpose of giving this citizenship test
the immigration test which we give is it
to measure what we're teaching in the
schools if it is how many different ways
are there to measure I've heard many
ways from the committee in the past and
those testifying from teachers from
those parents that there's different
ways to measure some students are not
very good test takers when it comes to
paper pencil
but when you see them actually
performing and able to accomplish what
you try to you taught you see a
different part of the equation so I I
think we need to be a little bit more
open in terms of looking at how we
assess and what ways we can we can uh
understand that the student has mastered
these skills and today in today's
society we have a lot of things we think
we're teaching at school but then you
start seeing some of the reactions and
occurrence which is occurring out there
in society today you see wow they really
didn't get
it and so this is this there's proof in
the pudding in this program right here
we see these kids doing what we want
through through the the the goals and
objectives and outcomes through our
Civics program so it's a it's a another
way that we we should be looking at in
terms of how we assess within our
schools um I'm not sold on that one test
is 120 questions we've got the answer
right there and that doesn't do it for
me I'm sorry represent
Damon thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my
question I'm wondering what data there
might be on how many students complete
the full I believe you said it was four
years Junior rzi
program and parallel to that if a
student is able to enroll only for a
much more finite per period of time it
would appear in the bill they would
still qualify to be exempt from the
exam the the uh program is a course or
courses so you get credit in a course
you don't have to be in it for four
years you can be in for two years if
you're like if you're in there two years
then you have you can have the option if
you go in the military to go in at a
higher rank which is a real savings and
and I went in my first pay for month and
when I went in as private e nothing was
$69 a month of course I got cigarettes
in the side and and everything else but
that was in that which I don't smoke but
um it's it's a significant increase in
pay and you know so then I had to
realize whoop I had a college degree
what am I doing as E1 after a year and a
half I went to OCS and became an officer
and and and and on so but this this
program right here is not you don't have
to be in at just four you can four four
years you can be in two years you can be
in for one
semester represent
Woodcock thank you chairman um afternoon
or almost afternoon any know I I I Rick
I totally concur with you in terms of
the value of these two programs without
a question um but I want to ask uh if uh
and I'm talking specifically because of
kenet Ken has a similar program uh with
youngsters in it and they're every day
taking a class they do stuff on
Saturdays they have uniform they do pt
they do the whole thing uh and they do
their uh you know their civic engagement
without a question uh and community
activities so I'm wondering but it
doesn't it's not one of these two
programs it's a similar program so I'm
wondering and and represent Miler
brought some of the other like School
similar programs would you be open to uh
an amendment that on this bill that adds
or similar programs I I think that I
would be on the condition that there's
specific criteria that's put down for
example the the program for the junior
roazzi program is approved by the board
there is a syllabus there is a program
developed I want to see that for these
other programs as well I think that
that's an absolute um if you have a
program which just is emerging and in
and it's may be sanctioned by the
particular school but as with any
program which you're going to get degree
credit those credit that has to be
approved through your school board
correct so I'd like to see that route
take and if some another program could
come up and do that I'm all for it thank
you thank you chair see no further
questions thank you very much oh I'm
sorry representative Cornell Thank you
and it this isn't really a question but
Manchester High School West is the naval
Roc just so I just want to throw that in
and seeing kids go into it I I actually
do think it's it's wonderful but they
wear their un it is a commitment they
wear their uniforms to school at least
one day a week um they accompany I
forget I just went blank with the flags
their
um what color the color guard you know
even when I was at the the middle school
we would request them to come and open
things for us with the color guard so it
is a commitment so I just it's a total
commitment I'm sorry you have a Navy
program rather than an army program you
know Navy got beaten last football game
thank you see no further questions thank
you very much and um I have one
additional card but without a name was
there someone else who wanted to speak
on this
bill that's my card that's your you
Ford
sitting before you at this time is one
of those students you're talking about I
was the Battalion commander of a
battalion of army rooc students my
school every week we held a
parade and I stood there and this is the
part you're not hearing from the
association next to my female compat rot
who was called a sponsor who held the
same rank I
did and we initiated a formal Battalion
review
parade every
week in between that week we attended
classes we studied literary history of
the military we studied the military
history along with the government and in
the summer if we chose we could go to
summer camp where I learned to use my
minimal athletic skills in clambering
over various obstacles without much
grace I must admit but I got
over that's what I learned the important
thing is to get
over to accomplish the mission you set
out to
accomplish at whatever
cost that's a lesson you don't learn in
civics class how can I say that because
I took
Civics
also and I took
math I took the Navy
Roc scholarship
yeah I get out of jail free card all I
had to do was not be drafted I just had
to tell him I had
polio and what did I
do I kept my mouth
shut I went off to college and took my
scholarship and passed my
physical and I went into the
Navy and I was in the Navy as a
midshipman on board a ship doing all
that fun
stuff the ship I was on had previously
had an accident it was an aircraft
carrier plane was coming in as you
probably all know they hooked their tail
hook on a little cable and that goes
across and they are arrested and they
land on the
deck except the cable
broke and it cut across the deck cut 44
people off at the
knee
Civics
101 freedom is not without
cost thank you very much your
representative um any
questions uh see none thank you very
much that with that we will close the
hearing on House Bill
1166 and um House Bill 11 excuse me
house bill 1397 is our last before lunch
the prime sponsor is uh not here um is
bill all you have to do is say you
beler the prime sponsor hold on
represent Bel she's right out in the
is
representative
okay
Alicia leus Hillsboro 38 and I'm here to
um for a number of years now our state
education system by law has been based
on
competencies but
unfortunately by practice we haven't
seen that as much and I asked numerous
times why
are kids wasting time taking
are not at the level they're at whether
they are bored because they know it all
or whether they are totally confused
because they're not there yet why are we
having them spend a year sitting in a
class that is inappropriate for them
when we're Competency Based and we
should be placing them in classes based
on their competency in that area and so
I've been asking that question and all
I've gotten is well well that's the law
the law is that we can do that we
already took care of that we passed a
law and it through a lot of questioning
and trying to figure out well if that's
the law why aren't we doing it what I
have pretty much discovered is we're
doing it we're not doing it because most
people don't know and so every school is
required to have an
exam that's part of that Competency
Based law
that every student is every school is
required to have an exam for all of
their tasks all of their classes I'm
sorry
um that a kid can take right and that's
also part of the law but the thing is
nobody knows well not nobody but an
awful lot of people don't know and so
all this is doing is saying let's make
sure everybody knows and so it just says
that the schools need to put in their
student handbook whatever those uh
procedures are which by law they have to
have so to be generous we'll assume that
all schools have those have already done
all of those all they have to do is
publish it in their student handbook and
that way a kid can sit and go oh I've
learned all this stuff already I can
take the test and go on to the next
level of this course which makes better
use of my limited time in school I mean
you only have four years in high school
and if you're taking you're forced to
take the lower level classes you may
never get to the higher level classes in
that four years but if you already know
the material you take the exam you move
to the next level and that way in your
four years you can get all the way up to
calculus or whatever it is that you're
trying to get to and so this just lets
the students and the parents know this
is the procedure so if you think you
belong in a different class you can take
the test and that'll help determine
which class you really should be in
that's what this is about thank you very
much there questions from the committee
representative Belcher thank you Mr
chair and thank you rep leus uh I
generally think that the principle
behind this is okay but I have a
question about the language on so here
it says uh under Article Five here it
says a student is placed in a course
based on achievement of the compet
competencies contained within the course
shouldn't that actually be a reference
to the competencies of the prerequisites
itself
um I would I I can see that either way
if they're based based on the
competencies it means have they already
completed those competencies and if they
have not then they should be in that
course as opposed to the next course
which if they have completed the
competencies
so I can see that work wording working
either
way uh I I have a question for you uh
within Ed 306 schools are required to
have at least 43
courses and competency associated with
those but you're also talking of primary
grades
and primary grades K through if it's
going up through
the the actually Elementary could be K8
or middle school four through um I'm I'm
concerned
that that they're going to have to have
in this
handbook
um information regarding the course so
now what are we going to put in there
for kindergarten or first grade what
about it might be math and the
competencies that have to be recover
covered in math in the first grade and
you may have a kid who's
already maybe they have older siblings
and they talk about all of this and
they're at that point or Beyond and they
really should be when the school when
their class is doing third grade be with
the third grade
you know Swap and then come back and the
same thing with reading you may have
kids who are very good readers and can
um during that time period That's
focused on reading or math not the time
periods that you're also including
reading in your history and all that
other stuff but that which is focused on
actually teaching reading skills they
might be moving to a different classroom
for that and I think if um I think
that's one of the things that we're
missing particularly in the elementary
schools is being able to move kids based
on their competency in a subject because
you may have a kid who's an excellent
reader and doesn't no math at all so
just putting them in first grade may not
be best effect the best for them and
their learning it may be better to have
them go to a second or third grade class
in their reading and maybe that third
grader who still doesn't get how reading
works coming to their room during that
instructional period but then the
opposite for math so this gives kids it
gives it more of an ability for kids to
be taught where they're at thank you
further questions representative uh
Cornell then represent thank you thank
you for taking the question so you would
assume that every class in the building
is teaching math at the same time no but
I I know that that I don't assume that
but I do assume that people are flexible
and that they can figure something out
and the reason that is I I went to a
small Elementary School and yet in my
school the teachers talked to each other
and they were able to say okay I have
this student or I have this student
let's get together and figure out how we
can do this and they did and that was
more than one different School District
cuz we had moved partway through through
and in each School District we had that
very thing and not only that we had
teachers who were more comfortable
teaching particular topics and they
actually even
though fifth grade say everybody is in
fifth grade with has one
teacher my fifth grade teachers one was
good at teaching English and one was
good at teaching science and they
arranged between the two of them to
teach English and science back to back
so that they could swamp
who taught that subject and so I believe
it can be done follow up yes and I don't
see a timeline on this so if halfway
through the school year they take the
assessment they would move to the next
so in high school if they do all the
algebra they need to do and it's halfway
through the year they would move on to
the next math class and they would have
missed the whole first half of the class
in that case they would have have to
take the competency for that first half
because a lot of the schools work by
semesters and you have a semester final
and so you could you would have to take
that not just the semester final for the
algebra but say if the next thing is
geometry you'd have to take that final
for that first semester in order to move
to the other to show that you know that
material and you're not going to be
missing it well but if they pass the
algebra one and they don't pass the
geometry one where do they go to class
unfortunately they're going to be stuck
in algebra one thank you I mean you can
only do so
much further questions from the
you good morning question on um the
comcy leas
if before I go into a second class I've
come in I've come to the um graduate
from grade 8 promoted from grade8 to
grade n in high school uh and I think
I'm pretty sharp in English and
literature The Freshman Basics whatever
they happen to be could be Grandma
whatever they teach um so I take the
competency class for competency for that
grade nine class whatever the sequence
happens to be and I pass it now does
that mean I'm opting out of the grade
nine does that mean I get credit for the
class I've never taken or am I just
waving that class requirement and moving
into grade 10 English you're w that c
requirement and moving
into grade 10 English so I don't I won't
be okay that's fine just so I won't be
receiving credit for grade nine English
I just basically popped waved out of it
into a high low okay thank you thank you
chairman L yes represent
Hall thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so I'm curious if
a school district wrote in their in
their handbook we support differentiated
instruction they off the
hook well because if by law they have to
have a method for determining competency
so I don't see how that does that I
don't see how that makes them off the
hook by just saying we support this it's
not giving the um method which they have
to have by
law follow up yes so if I have a fifth
grade math class and I have a student in
there is really at the eighth grade
level but he's in my class
different differentiate instruction
tells me as a teacher I need to be
teaching him at the e8th grade level
well in that case you would you would
have to in the student handbook explain
that's what I mean the method for not
just if you say well we have
differentiated instruction that doesn't
tell anybody how that has to be done and
so the handbook like I said I'm not
changing what a school has or has to do
that's already in law I'm saying saying
what is the method for it to be done so
if I was the fifth grader or you were
the teacher of the fifth grader and you
think they should have eighth grade you
both need to know how that happens and
so that's what I'm asking for what is
what is the method how does that happen
what do you as the teacher what do you
as the student
do to be in the eighth grade class as
opposed to the fifth grade
class I'll talk to you later for the
question but I do can I can I go back
and respond again because no I'd like to
have questions coming to you I meant the
question that she asked but we're we're
on to other people right now and so
further questions represent
Tanner thank you um I take a little
umbrage to uh wasting time in a
classroom and I'm just wondering if you
if you have any idea of what else might
be going on in classroom that couldn't
be tested out
I can tell you that a portion of my
ninth grade class wasted time an entire
year in math and therefore didn't get to
take all the math classes that we had
wanted to take because we were sitting
through a class we already had taken but
didn't have credit for and we spent time
either doing homework or passing notes
or whatever and the teacher said as long
as your quiet and you don't disturb
anybody else and you can continue to get
A's on the tests I don't care I did
myself and two of the other students did
manage to get that changed for students
coming up behind but yes if you're if
you know the
material in effect you are wasting that
chunk of time that could be spent
learning new things and that's what I'm
referring to you have a limited number
of
years that you are in school and so to
sit through a class that's teaching
material that you already know when you
could be learning new
material and therefore get more out of
your education I'm not saying don't take
any classes I'm saying move on to the
next so you get as much knowledge as you
can in the time that you're in
school other questions from the
committee thank you very
much uh we have one other card no we
don't
no any other car people from the public
thank you very much with that we're
going to close this hearing
e
uh thank you yeah thank you very much uh
we'll start afternoon session um with
House Bill
1476 relative Charter to Charter School
memorandums of understanding and uh
representative Cornell will introduce
it thank you representative Patricia
Cornell
District 22 Manchester's w 11 this is
1476 relative to Charter School
memorandums of understanding and
basically the only thing that this bill
does is change the dates of when the
memor memorandum of understanding will
go into effect and change it prior to
the school till November 1st um the
reason for that is many Charters and
public schools don't have staff work
during the summer that would be working
on the IEP so it it puts everyone behind
to have to have it ready for the first
day of school and it also provides more
time to develop the um memorandums of in
of understanding in a meaningful way so
that's
it thank you for um your concise
presentation um any questions from the
Comm
seeing none thank you very much thank
you uh are there any other cards for
this
bill this 1467
yeah that's 37
okay uh I don't is there anyone else who
wanted to testify on this
Bill yes thank you
card uh good afternoon Melissa white
division director for learner Support
Department of
Education um with the fiscal note we
included um some information just re
some concerns with regards to this
proposed legislation um students that
are coming into the school year that
have an IEP that's already in effect
would then it's possible they would not
have Services provided until November
1st if we change that date so there is
some concerns around that in
addition waiting until November 1st to
get those Services lined up for those
students for example if you needed to
provide some sort of speech therapist or
some sort of services that were not
available that should be arranged prior
to the start of the school year and not
a few months after the school year
started so there's just some concerns
with some of the services for those
students
if we wait until that November 1st in
addition School budgets are determined
the year prior SO waiting to make all of
those decisions after the school year
started could potentially have a
negative impact on those districts
trying to negotiate and pay for those
services so just some potential um
unintended consequences that we wanted
forward thank you very much uh any
question questions for Miss
White um yes represent Damon thank you
Mr chair took a minute trying to figure
out how to ask this question sure thank
you so I don't think I understand the
different impact you noted potential
impact on school budgets from September
1st versus November 1st when the budgets
are crafted the year
before so they should be arranging for
those Services prior to the start of the
school year so if they have Theus
established prior to the school year
beginning that would have already been
accounted for as opposed to after the
school year
starts so there was just some concern
that um we wanted there could be some
potential issues we just wanted to
mention
that
sure but budgets are established in
March or May so I'm still confused May
so looking at some of those students
they may want to even be considered ing
year yes
oh
sorry Lakers I know it's hard isn't
it
um is there a
reason why these things can't be figured
out before the
end before everybody goes away for the
that would be a good recommendation to
figure it out before the end of the
school year especially if you already
know your students I mean you might have
students that are coming in at the
beginning of the school year that you
may not have anticipated coming into the
charter school but if you have those
students that you know are from this
District but are going to this Charter
School yes it would make sense
to you could speak a little closer and
that goes all board members had issues
with people hearing us so you know if we
all speak closer the mic mhone will be
I'll use my teacher voice there you go
so yes it would make sense for to make
those arrangements prior to even you
know ending the school year but there
was just the concern with the start of
November 1st particularly that could
have some unintended consequences we
just want to be aware of thank
you further
questions I seeing none thank you very
here
was there anyone else who wanted to
it
okay we're uh on to our next bill for
the afternoon which is hb1 1437 relative
to the membership of the State Board of
Education and the prime sponsor is ready
U represent Tanner thank you Mr chair
and thank you honorable committee
members um for the record my name is
Linda Tanner I represent Sullivan
District 5 which is the beautiful towns
of Springfield and
sopy um I've given you two handouts that
have kind of come around and I thought
might add some important background
information one is the history of a New
Hampshire Board of Education that was
created in
1919 and 1919 was a world shaking year
uh America was recovering from World War
I and
were setting off bombs labor unions Were
Striking in shipyards even the women's
telephone operators went out on strike
and the 18th Amendment um authorizing
prohibition as well as the 19th
Amendment giving women suffrage were
passed um so it was a pretty pretty
hectic year but probably the worst thing
that happened was that b Babe Ruth was
sold by the Boston Red Sox to the New
York Yankees for
$125,000 will the will the member
suspend
and thus began the 84 years of the curse
of the Bambino that was solved in 2004
needless to say it was a turbulent time
um but it was also the time that New
Hampshire realized that to cherish
education as our constitution prescribes
needed some drastic changes to reach the
many citizens who could not read it
right at that time um particularly in
the rural areas the the major um
Industrial areas of Claremont Manchester
NASA and the Sea Coast were really going
uh pretty well and their schools were
doing very well but out in the
hinterland it wasn't quite as good uh
the governor at that time Bartlett um
and the Le John Bartlett and the
legislators um legislature created a
commission or of Education position in
the State Board of Education was formed
um so it's over a 100 years old the
balance was stated by having politically
spirited and interested citizens on a
Board of Trustees type uh board that was
complemented with a um quoted skilled
executive officer who had training and
experience in educational work the hand
on on History gives you a unique view of
the thoughts and debates recorded that
year uh many concerns and duties remain
to this day of the of the State Board of
Education the establishment of the board
stated that no more than three members
out of their five could be of one party
and that no technical educator or
persons professionally engaged in
schoolwork could serve so they were
trying to make it um very
nonpartisan the state school board was
changed several times over the last 100
years eliminating regulations and duties
and expanding others the pro prohibition
on technical educators of those
professionally engaged in schoolwork has
remained I am proposing that we we need
need to change we need to bring a change
to the board State Board of Education
the state school board's role has been
evolving over a hundred years and you
can see on that one sheet all the
different duties they had starting out
with um but particularly in the last two
or three decades overseeing our state
education system is very complex and
requires expertise in many areas
building Aid Charter Schools remote
learning um Extended Learning
opportunities funding for special
education adequate
uh the state standards uh credentialing
and the state's obligation and school
funding just to name a few our
postsecondary education system has
expanded as well and needs
representation on the board not only are
there many many issues reports and
decisions that the State Board of
Education is charged with in statute at
this time and it's hard to find them all
because they're spread out throughout
the statutes quite a bit um but issues
in education at all levels increased uh
became more complex and require a great
deal of attention and expertise both in
the field of Education as well as
Finance law and
business I would like to propose we now
have seven positions on the State Board
five of those positions are designated
so that there's one from each executive
Council District the other two are at
large I am proposing that we increase
the board to 11 members by including a
public school classroom teacher a public
School administrator a public school
superintendent and a student um and that
student I would almost suggest would be
from our legislative youth advisory
Council I think if you look on the sheet
where I listed the different uh States
and how their state board of education
um is comprised several of them have a
student representative on the board and
several states have actually done
reorganization of their State Board of
Education in the last decade um this
would give the board more people to put
on subcommittees to study issues and
handle the many tasks and reports that
they're charged with the inclusion of
Educators in the student would give the
board more insight and information from
the people delivering the education to
the students of our state and what's
going on right now as you can see on the
second handout uh as I said it gives you
a glimpse of the other states that that
uh have prescribed positions for parents
for example would be good to have a
parent on the state school board and my
favorite is one state has a non- voting
place for the teacher of the year uh so
the teacher of the year is appointed for
a year and then the next year serves on
the state school
board no other state that in New England
that I uh researched has prohibition
against technical Educators but instead
Embraces many stakeholders including
Educators I realize this is a major
change and should have input from all
stakeholders to form a board whose
composition better represents the
stakeholders in our public school system
while maintaining positions for spirited
citizens interested in gaining an
understanding of the educational need of
the state and the best way to supply
them uh as in the original charter um
other states have have developed the
commission to look at composition and
duties of the State Board of Education
as I said several of them have undergone
changes and reorganizations and I
suggest that this bill be a stepping off
point for that thank you uh thank you
representative questions representative
uh McDonald thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative Tanner for bringing
this forward and I really appreciate the
history lesson that you have in your
wrri testimony here um the 19th
amendment was ratified in 1920 not 1919
but not withstanding um was there a
particular incident that inspired this
bill in New
Hampshire um I think we've had numerous
occasions in this this um this committee
to see uh some of the issues that are
really going before the State Board of
Education and how complex they are
probably the 306s was one that uh really
uh kind of Jarred me into the into uh
suggesting this that uh we really um
have gone round and round about the
transparency and actually the 19th
amendment was passed in 1919 but then
ratified in 20 you're ready all right
thank
you further questions representative
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for bringing this bill forward uh so my
question is
that generally speaking so we
don't as a society as a government we
don't allow people actively employed in
the pharmaceutical industry to regulate
Pharmaceuticals we don't act we don't
allow people actively employed in
banking to regulate the the banking
industry so I'm wondering why this
General principle of people should not
be placed in a position to regulate the
field in which they are employed why
should that not hold true here first of
all I I kind of disagree with your
initial premise that that people from
different Industries uh certainly uh
Janet Yellen is pretty versed in um
financial matters and has worked in
financial
institutions um and I think we also
depend on lobbyists from time to time
from different groups to write our bills
uh and we've had bills that have been
produced here from the State Department
of Education uh that were written by
them so to try to exclude people who
have educational experience and
educational Knowledge from such a
fundamental part of what our school
system is our state education system is
I think is a is a gross uh
mistake
follow if I may just to clarify um is
there a difference in your mind between
those actively employed in educating and
those who have General experience and
knowledge um you know whether there is
any general experience and knowledge
already on the
board I think that the board has to have
input and should have
representation they're still going to
maintain those five people one from each
district in the in the two people that
are at large so they still have the
fundamental basics of the board the
thing that they this bill does is add to
it the student and the people that are
involved in public education now in
order to participate on the board I'm
probably going to say it's like
participating on this education
committee uh if you're an active teacher
active
superintendent um even if you're a
student it it's going to be difficult
for you to come to a state Board of
Education that meets on a Thursday from
8:00 in the morning or 9:00 in the
morning until whenever they get work
done so I see it more I think what is
going to happen is it probably be people
retired or people that are on sabatical
this further questions representative
dry thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
taking my question so in this committee
we've been trying to reduce um committee
rzes um a lot because of the you know
there's a certain number when you get
things get start to get um difficult and
combersome to do business and I usually
see expansion on committees if there's a
problem like getting a quorum or um
people showing up to this do you have
any idea if people on the State Board of
Education have been like diligent to
show up is there any problem in that
area well I know they do remote so uh
the people can come in on remote to the
the State Board of Education I think
committees uh need to be big enough so
that they can handle all the duties and
like I said if you if you have a weekend
where you would like to peruse through
just the small booklet that we have on
the education laws and underline all the
places where the St State Board of
Education either has a report or as part
of a decision-making process um you'd be
amazed I mean I I gave up after a while
it was just too many and I think having
more people and again looking at some of
these boards in Massachusetts Rhode
Island Vermont uh Maine that that they
often have subcommittees that they have
for example one one of the states and I
can't remember exactly which one is had
a subcommittee just for secondary Ed for
post-secondary Education which probably
wouldn't be a bad idea for our our board
to do but with only seven people on the
board I think um expanding it to 11 is
not going to make uh any
overdue uh burden on the number of
people follow follow up go ahead thank
you so the we're increasing it by about
more than 50% um there's a geographic
restriction on a number of the members
already but it doesn't seem like there's
any Geographic constriction on what you
want to put in right it's it's moving
from 7 to 11 which is not
50% um but it's it's also that when the
first uh School Board of Education was
devised uh one of the in in the history
lesson that's in here um they wrote
extensively about it there was a real um
effort to get to to get down on writing
what actually people were thinking about
at the time and of course there weren't
professional Educators at the time um
except at the college level and they um
wanted people from all Pursuits uh
agricultural Financial you know
different they actually listed out
different areas that they wanted people
from and they wanted spirited citizens
that would be interested in learning
about education and helping provide this
new educational system that was going to
put State funding into rural areas um
start credentialing teachers and uh
people that worked in schools and like I
said now we're from those basic 13 12 or
13 duties they had we are up in the
probably several hundred duties that
they have thank you further questions
from the committee thank you very much
you're
[Music]
bitman
hello um I am uh speaking on HB 1437 I'm
opposed to this um couple of things that
um representative beler already
mentioned that I felt like that the
classroom teacher and administrator and
such should not be on uh the school
board I was uh fortunate enough to work
with a gentleman in my town uh who
needed to clean out his basement he was
87 years old and his wife collected
every single newspaper of Our Town
Newspaper and um in one of the Articles
as we were going through because he was
looking for something I don't remember
which article he was looking for but
there was very big discussion back in
the early 80s about having teachers on
the school board in the small town and
my small town we used to have little
school houses um because and then we
didn't even have a kindergarten until in
the'80s
1980s so um very small town in New
Boston so there was very big discussion
now granted at that point the reason to
have the teachers not be on the school
board was because of contractual and
having influence over that um my concern
is is if there needs to be an increased
number in uh people on this committee
why aren't you increasing that each
district has one more person from it um
also on line 14 um terms of office said
for four years on the State Board of
Education uh website it says it's a
5-year term I don't know which one's
incorrect um because I'm not
knowledgeable on that and um so and if
you need experts and you are allowed to
go to the State Board of Education I've
gone there a couple times and voice your
concerns and test and do testimony you
can do remote testimony just like here
so it's not like we can't have that
expert um opinion or information and
then you you have one teacher and I will
tell you a middle school teacher High
School teacher and elementary teacher
school teacher have vast difference
views about what is needed in a school
and what they would like to have focused
on in a school so that's it thank you
thank you very much uh are you willing
to take questions sure are there any
questions from the committee I doubt it
oh thank you very much thank you uh I'd
Klein
welcome uh thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee uh I'm Drew Klein I am
chairman of the State Board of Education
I'm speaking here strenuously in
opposition to hb1 1437 I submitted a
written testimony through the web portal
which you probably don't have yet um
because I submitted it right before it
came so I won't go into great depth but
I will just outline the bullet points of
my testimony that I submitted online
um when you look back to the origin of
the State Board of Education in 1919 is
and you read the legislative debates and
the house committee House Education
committee uh records from back then it
is crystal clear that the legislature
intended to create a very Democratic
Board of Education a very democratic
system of oversight of public education
the State Board of Education is a gem
it's a democratic gem in New Hampshire's
governance
structure they intended very very
specifically to create citizen oversight
of professional Educators and I'd like
to correct something you said earlier
there were in fact professional
Educators in New Hampshire in the early
20th century the Board of Education was
created to create citizen oversight of
professional Educators in my written
testimony I quote some of the findings
from that committee
um New Hampshire's structure was uh
largely copied from Vermont which had
passed something similar a few years
before they only spelled out two
criteria for Board of Education members
that you not be
paid and that you be a lay person who
was not currently a practicing educator
and those were very deliberate they
didn't want the board to be corrupted by
any sort of compensation they wanted
them to be volunteers citizen volunteers
years and they
wanted in the records you can see they
wanted to prevent factionalism that
would happen by having professional
Educators serving on the oversight board
so there were two things and to
representative bel's point that they
were very clear they wanted to avoid was
micromanaging content and stuff that
really ought to belong at the local
level and one of their fears was if you
put professional Educators on the State
Board of Education they would get mired
down in these factional conflicts
between differences of opinion
about content curriculum pedagogical
stuff practice all those things they did
they wanted to keep that off of the
State Board of
Education and they wanted to prevent
corruption and by that I mean just very
simply it is good standard governance
practice to not have professionals on
the board overseeing themselves so they
wanted to draw a clear
line this bill would destroy that
balance over the years this the
legislature has seen fit to create
structures to give the State Board of
Education made up of lay people input
from professional Educators so the
legislature created the Professional
Standards
Board the Professional Standards Board
advises the Board of Education when we
do rulemaking they give us very
good insightful input that we listen to
very attentively we do have
communications with professional
Educators not only do we get that
through the Professional Standards Board
which really drafts the first draft of
all of our rules that govern um
licensing and that sort of thing for for
educators that first draft comes
from professional Educators is not
thought up by the the lay people on the
board of ed so we take that and then we
go it and review it and tweak it and
make it our own or sometimes we take it
as it is because we don't have any
changes um and we take input we have
public hearings all the rul making goes
through regular process we have public
hearings and those public hearings
typically if anyone shows up at all it's
professional Educators who show up um so
I'll leave it at that um I think this
would seriously um upend the sort of
civilian
oversight that the legislator created
105 years ago that works very well in
New Hampshire and in fact um
Massachusetts also prohibits uh
professional Educators from serving on
their Board of Education uh in my
written testimony I I think I wrote that
I was drafting the end of it very
quickly I think I said that no New
England State um has professional
Educators on their board uh Connecticut
is the one state that has the teacher of
the year serve a one-year term on their
Board of Ed
but nowhere else that I was able to find
does that thank you very much Mr clown I
have a question for you yeah um when we
are serving by that the public as well
on a commission such as we have the
Civics commission going on right now
prior to serving one has to fill out a
form from the Secretary of State's
office declaring if whe they have any
conflict of interest ET could you please
explain uh how that works and why we
have it
well uh we have to fill up Financial
disclosure forms as well uh for the
State Board of Education and the point
is to um disclose to the members of the
public if you being compensated by any
uh entity that you regulate to avoid a
conflict of interest so um hb1 1437
would clearly uh run in contradiction to
that disclosure um and the concept
behind that disclosure that you don't
have a financial interest in the um
professionals professions that you're
regulating
we also have and just to make a final
Point
um we we write rules for educators and
we have Educators some testify in those
rules and sometimes you have difference
of opinion between teachers and uh
principles and superintendents on how
these things and we take a lot of
feedback we work very well I think with
a lot of those professional
organizations um we strive very hard to
to take their input seriously and to get
um develop good relationships with them
um it would clearly be a conflict of
interest to have a sitting practicing
education professional writing the rules
that that govern those education
professionals there's just no way around
that thank you very much are there
further questions from the committee yes
represented
Balon thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I'm sorry I don't
know this but maybe it's publicized
somewhere but um how are members of the
State Board of Education chosen is there
not appliation process um they're
selected by the governor and approved by
the executive counsel in some States
they're confirmed by the state senate I
think our system works a little better
um they uh the governor reaches out to
people sometimes they apply to the
governor sometimes they you know let the
governor know they're interested in
serving but um just speaking for myself
I got a phone call out of the blue so
sometimes they the governor has people
choose further questions from the
committee thank you very much all right
thank you yep
uh Becky Wilson is nhba going to take a
position do you have any technical
or uh good afternoon members of the
House side committee for the record my
name is Becky Wilson I am the director
of governmental relations for the New
Hampshire school boards Association we
are not taking a position on this bill
uh however we would like to suggest uh a
potential Amendment to the language of
the bill which would incorporate the
voice of a Public School District School
Board member and at least one Public
School Board student representative to
be considered and the potential list of
members uh for the State Board um as you
know I'm sure in this committee local
Schoolboard policies are found
throughout the New Hampshire State Board
of Ed rules and having somebody at the
local level who has experience
operationalizing and writing those
policies es would be very useful uh also
out of this committee uh last year as
you know beginning January of 2023 every
Public School Board in New Hampshire has
at least one student representative if
they have a high school within their
jurisdiction uh we have certainly seen
the value of that student voice over the
past year uh in cooperation with the New
Hampshire school administrators
Association uh NH hsba has held several
trainings for student Schoolboard reps
on the role of the Schoolboard rep as a
student writing Schoolboard reports Etc
uh we've had over 50 students
participate in those trainings over the
past year uh so we certainly we want to
reiterate that while we're not taking a
position on the bill as written we would
respectfully ask that you consider the
addition of those two positions thank
you further questions from the
committee not seeing thank you very much
thank
you with that I don't have any other
pink cards on on this bill 1437 then
we're closing the hearing and we'll get
ready to get into the next hearing which
will be
here
mic there's a 1205 up here
too
yes
[Music]
okay
a couple cards yeah can you please ask
represent cascan and she's going to
introduce the bill she is I need a pink
her no no no no would you please ask
repr Andre there on the table over there
whether she's going to speak she's the
me
police because it always stretches in
yeah
I'd like to take this opportunity to
welcome everybody to the education
committee uh we are here today to look
at HB 1205 that's relative to women's
School sports and at this time I'd like
to invite forward the prime sponsor of
Andress okay and for for the record as
information here due to the number of
cards which we have the process which we
have here in education is that we allow
the prime sponsor the time that the
prime sponsor needs to introduce the
bill so we don't put a time limit we
will be putting time limit on everybody
else who speaks today and most likely by
looking at the car uh crowd here it's
going to be about two minutes per person
so with that I'd like to go ahead and
welcome representa
Andrew
thank you honorable education committee
for taking my testimony
today for the record I am representative
Louise Anders and I represent Mart
County District 5 and of dber Hill salur
and
Webster I am here as the prime sponsor
on house bille 12205 relative to women's
sports or by a more familiar title fness
in women's
sports I stand here to today as a 100%
supporter of safety and fairness in
biological female School sports which is
House Bill 12
1205 but I want to make known that I
will not take credit for creating or
writing this bill rather I am the
Messenger and in support 100% of House
Bill 1205 the creation and writing of
the bill was formulated by a group of
citizens in Newberry known as the
Coalition of Newberry conservatives I
understand that the group obtained
copies of all past bills which is
attached to the information I gave to
you then they went through all the bills
read every one of them and the bill was
deriv to fit New Hampshire's
needs one of its members Stephanie
Spalding contacted me and asked I if I
would consider sponsoring the bill my
answer was yes as I knew our biological
females in New Hampshire needed
sports Riley gains a strong advocate for
safe fair and impost practices Sports
said quote there is a place for everyone
one to play sports in this country
unquote I agree with this statement and
House Bill 205 make safe and fair
Sports according to a NBC news report
approximately
70% of all Americans do not want
biological males and bi biological
female
sports following is a link in the
testimony that I have given you
relating to the
article at the current time there are 24
states that have passed builds which
protect female
athletes states that have protected
female athletes are Alabama Arizona
Arkansas Florida Idaho Indiana Iowa
Kansas Kentucky Louisiana Mississippi
Missouri Montana Nebraska North Carolina
North Dakota Oklahoma
South Dakota Tennessee Texas Utah West
Virginia and the latest being Georgia
and
Ohio why do we need House Bill 1205 to
become
law our biological females in New
Hampshire need protection in safety in
sports for biological males and fness in
sports I was reading an
article from Alliance defending freedom
of which I am including the link with my
written
testimony the article in physical
differences
quote some of the advantages of
biological males over biolog iCal
females quote greater height and weight
and larger longer and stronger bones to
larger muscles and higher rates of
metabolizing and releasing
energy these innate physiological traits
result in Greater muscle
strength stronger throwing hitting and
kicking higher jumping and faster
running speeds for males all of which
create an athletic Edge over females
unquote for these traits at a biological
male competing in sports has and will
continue to cause physical harm to
female athletes our biological females
deserve to play sports on a Level
Playing Field we have biological females
that work hard all open school in a
sport that they love and compete in and
win then maybe Along Comes a biological
male who competes and wins where is the
fairness fairness is without
discrimination and when a biological
male is allowed to compete in a
discrimination I am including in my
written testimony a few of many many
links found on the internet where
biological males have entered into and
one or Advanced well in a biological
female
sport the links I have included in my
testimony for your perusal
a biological men have won 28 women's
sport Titles since
2003 B a biological male rising to
fourth place in biological female
Runners and place
172nd in biological
females in in males see where where
biological male students took home top
prizes of the state championships for
biological females D the biological male
at kiad Regional school that came in
1600 need to run and fifth in girls high
jump yet if the biological male had
completed in the boys division placed
him near the bottom 50th out of
56 I stand with all biological females
that we can obtain 100% safety and
fairness in women's sports by passing
House Bill
1205 respectfully representative Louis
Andrew thank thank you very much
representative are there questions that
you would take from the
committee yeah okay uh committee any
questions of the Senate not seeing thank
you very much thank you and going
forward I ask those that are coming up
and testimony that have a uh a written
copy a written form of some man would
you please just submit it to the
representative over here to by the door
his hands up and he'll submit it and
it'll be put into the record please
don't read it verbatim try to summarize
and remember there are only a couple
minutes for each person we will start
off with number of representatives in
this room have to be out to other
meetings currently so I'm going to start
right off with representative Jess
Edwards
uh thank you chairman lad and uh thank
you for the time for the uh education
committee I'm going to keep it to one to
two minutes it's quick um quick quick
and simple uh I'm representative Jess
Edwards I represent uh Rockingham
District
31 uh I've gotten a lot of input from my
community a lot of people who generally
oppose me have asked me to support
1205 uh I would have supported 1205
anyways I have two mothers Five Sisters
two daughters and a granddaughter there
are no men associated with my family
it's all women that I'm very proud of
very strong people I served 33 years in
the Army to try to go find some somebody
other than the women in my life so I I
found some men to hang out with but
while I was there I also found out that
we had a tremendous number of women who
served and as one of the officers my job
included making sure that everyone was
physically capable of serving in a
hostile combat environment it was a very
exacting very demanding uh realistic
environment that we train people for
and when we do this we use a physical
fitness test in the army that gets
normed differently so that's it's easier
for women to get a very high score
compared to men uh I was an okay athlete
I never got a pretty good score I got
okay scores uh but women were constantly
getting uh perfect scores for doing much
less than me and they were advantaged by
promotions and being recognized and the
like which is all fine and great um so
so the
Army even though we trained for the same
environment we trained to different
physical standards we did that because
in the military you have
to take care that you practice reality
so this was reality-based training sex
segregation makes sense gone beyond your
two minutes can I just two two s so my
dad taught me men don't hit women and
men should help women protect female
sport not destroy them female sport
makes sense thank you thank you very
much are there questions for the
representative thank you very much uh
Moffett famous here moving fast here I
know you're uh have some limits on time
uh nice to be back in education uh I'm
for the record Mike mord marac for
Canterbury Lowden also a sports guy as
some of you know uh ref from Conway I
think reads my sports column from time
to time or so I heard so anyway uh uh
can 10 seconds say again rip from Conway
my wife lik oh uh for the record his
wife likes my sports col all right so
back to my time um this is not as easy
topic as some people may think I was on
this committee three years a we had a
during Co we had a hearing uh 32 out of
33 people who testified were were
standing up for their trans kids and
that changed me moved the needle for me
broaden my awareness understand them ADV
advocating for the kids now there's
other parents who also going to advocate
for their kids in a different way you'll
hear from them today I am a
co-sponsor um there mostly moms uh but
also dads so I want to make one point
and it has to do with safety uh I had a
couple daughters who played soccer
conquered High School Crimson Tide one
was a goalkeeper one was a striker if
anybody ever had a kid who's a
goalkeeper it's no fun to watch you
watch a kid out scoring so anyway
conquered at glown my daughter Katie was
a goalkeeper a 5050 ball two uh people
going different directions for the ball
Collision broken leg uh ambulance on the
field screaming um it was not my
daughter broke her leg it was the other
girl who ran into my daughter uh so uh
5050 balls those of you are sports
people 5050 balls when there's two
people the same shot at the ball happens
in field hockey happens in ice hockey
certainly happens in soccer so my point
I want to make is that with these 5050
balls I Katie was 120 pounds or whatever
and she went in there and broke the leg
of somebody who was 120 pounds but if
you have a 100 pound
girl and 160 170 pound uh XY chromosome
guy it's a safety issue it's something
that needs to be acknowledged and
addressed so what's the answer I think
the answer is to go xx and XY that's the
only clear way to address the safety
issue so uh thank you for the two
minutes Mr chair I'll take a question if
there are any thank you very much
questions from the committee thank you
thank you Mr chair you're welcome
represent
n thank you and good afternoon Mr
chairman and members of the committee um
I'm representative Jenny n Hillsboro 21
for the record I would have been the
prime sponsor of this bill but
representative Andrew got her in before
me so but I'm here today to um give my
support for the bill and we've had this
bill before of several times and uh
representative Andress talked about
greater weight height and weight there's
also the heart the lungs lung capacity
the hips um a biological mes hips are
narrower so they have the advantage of
running just kicking straight out
whereas women we tend to be a little
wider around the hips it kind of goes
around um and also the world stage is
taking notice to uh their policies that
biological males do have an advantage um
and to level the playing field they're
they're starting to no longer allow them
to compete with with women so as not to
contribute to the Eraser of women and
girls so I ask you to support the Bill
thank you thank you very much
representative any questions not see
thank
Willette thank you Mr chairman and
committee members
Title 9 came Title 9 came in law in 1972
to give females an equal opportunity of
sports it was not wildly accepted or
executed everywhere I get involved in
women's sports for this reason but being
a father of three daughters I would not
accept second class status of our local
athletes uh that they were
receiving I became involved in coaching
and eventually running a league as a
softball coach my team's won many state
championships uh New England Regional
championships even went to World Series
I was lucky enough to have won five New
Hampshire High School state
championships in
softball my daughter was a pitcher went
on a fine college career winning two
conference championships and being named
All-American she had an invitation to
play with the US Olympic team in Europe
and was recognized as Sports Illustrated
that's not bad for a kid from rural ca
County what this what do what does this
have to do with HB
125 with my exper experience I consider
myself a softball expert in women's
softball and I would not let my daughter
play against biological males there's
too much risk for physical harm never
mind the emotional issues having to
share a locker room with a biological
man I've witnessed girls breaking legs
arms jaw cheekbone playing against other
women adding males only increase their
injury rate to other females there are
many recent cases where trans play trans
players have H hospitalized female uh
athletes this past November our
Massachusetts high school field hockey
player was hit in the face had teeth
knocked out and hospitalized by a trans
player also last month a high school
volleyball player was hospitalized with
player now here's the heart of the
bill at many Rural High Schools having
enough members to feel the team can be
challenging many Junior High kids are
brought up to play Varsity my
granddaughter is one of these cases
she's an eighth grader and she is
developing into an Elite softball player
but to think this 13-year-old that
stands 5'1 and was 100 lb could be
standing on the mound 40t away facing an
18-year-old 6'2 220 lb man is
mortifying her mother will never let her
her mother will never let her be put in
a position to be severely injured your
so time is up so wrap it up please one
sentence yep so my granddaughter can't
play because someone else refused is to
play with physically equal players
please protect our daughters if you
cannot then just introduce legislation
to revoke Title 9 that's in essence what
is being done now thank you thank you
very much questions from the committee
thank you very much you must know Dana
Huntington out of uh
Woodsville he's uh very well and I hate
playing against him yeah he's a good
coach he's a great coach thank you uh
representative Tim
kahill
thank you Mr chair good to see uh you
guys over at the education committee um
I'm here today in support of this bill
and more importantly in support of
fairness and women's sports uh I'm I'm a
surfer I'm a surf coach uh and I mainly
I only coach women and in my sport um
women have had to work extremely hard to
get to where they are in surfing for
example
on the pro level in surfing there's 50
men on the CT circuit but there's 18
women and if we don't take action to
protect women's sports we could be
taking a position away from a woman
that's earned a spot in the future or a
scholarship in their sport or all those
other things that they work to and I and
I just wanted to talk to that um issue
because if we're giving spots to men in
women's sports we're we're taking away
from their chance to succeed and some
some of those women have worked hard and
have earned the chance to get those
positions and they should have those
positions thank you very much for your
time thank you very much questions from
the committee thank you very
wood thank you Mr
chair button
y button will go red silver buttton yeah
yeah there you go okay sorry I didn't
realize it was on I should know right um
I'm also supporting this bill I wanted
to bring a different aspect to this uh
like some of the people who spoke
earlier I hear a lot from the mothers
the parents of of these uh children
playing sports um they have all the
general concerns of safety everything
that was brought up one of the things
that really bothered me was the uh
environment that uh
this is creating allowing uh this type
of uh change in the in the sport uh they
remind me of all the uh Medical Data out
there they remind me how hard it was for
women's sports to get
started they know all the answers uh
when I finally started asking them I
said how come your daughter's still
playing if it's so unfair we go always
back the fairness of safety and um
because it they're under stress not to
um quit the sport there there's public
pressure or peer pressure better word
peer pressure for them to stay with it
and um I started looking at incidents of
people who have spoken out athletes have
spoken out me there's plenty of evidence
out there that um they're targets and um
it's kind of concerning when I'm talking
to parents who don't want their kids in
there and the kids are fighting the play
uh in here because they don't want to
have that social stigma so I just want
to add a A Different Twist to it and
again this was from parents that have
speaking out and like Jesse mentioned
earlier representative mentioned early
there's a lot of parents speaking out on
this more than the uh women athletes I
believe thank you thank you very much
questions thank
Perez good afternoon committee thank you
for hearing my uh testimony my name is
representative Christine Perez I'm from
London area and represent Rockingham
district
16 um we have the distinct honor of
living in a country where we have the
privilege of electing individuals to
represent us and to legislate laws that
govern all of
us that exact definition of our Republic
we may not always agree with who was
elected or what laws are pass but we are
bound to obey those that we were with
that we chose we freely elected that
being said we are all acutely aware in
this Society under circumstances we
cannot provide 100% of equity meaning
the quality of being fair and
imparable for 100% of individuals 100%
of the time but we have a Duty and as
free people to provide dignity fairness
and safety for the majority in all
situations this is one of those
situations where Equity must be provided
for the majority I do understand if you
have some res reservations about the
wording of some of the of this bill and
I ask you to amend it but I implore you
not to give this up this bill is simply
about making and doing what is right for
the majority in a free society that is
governed by the majority don't make more
out of this than it is don't Cloud its
intent with things that it is not and I
thank you thank you very much other
questions from the committee thank you
s
s ORS
ORS a r e s that's it got it thank you
Mr chair and thank you for hearing my
testimony I'm representative sah orus
from Chai Chester uh back in the day I
used to be a FIFA referee for those of
you that live in this country on this
side of the pond it's called soccer on
the other side of the pond that's called
Football Federation of International
Football Association and with that I
just wanted to share that as a referee
and a coach of several teams travel
teams home teams that sort of thing uh I
have seen the disparity in physical
ability between men and women if you
will and my daughter was permanently
injured her right eye by a biological
male when uh she was taken down and
kicked accidentally I'm sure but my
point is being a referee and being a
coach over the years I have seen this
disparity of size and strength and I
would wish you would consider that as as
you go forward thank you very much thank
you questions questions from the
committee now see you thank you very
much thank you didn't miss a great
questions we want to know how it's on
the other side of the pond oh it's good
Chris
urel sorry be here in just a moment okay
Reed hi thank you so much for taking the
time to hear my testimony uh for the
record my name is Courtney Reid and I
serve as policy Advocate with the ACLU
of New Hampshire and I wanted to speak
in opposition to this bill as it raises
serious concerns uh of constitutional
concerns and would allow for
discrimination based on sex in New
Hampshire um one of the representatives
have brought up Title
9 uh this bill would violate federal law
it would violate Title Nine of the Civil
Rights Act which has a a clear uh
requirement that in schools receiving
Federal funding educational programs
cannot discriminate on the basis of sex
and that's exactly what this bill would
do
and that it categorically would prohibit
transgender women and intersect people
from participating in sports teams or in
any team uh I think the the bill
references requiring competitive
skill
um bills like this have been brought to
the courts and numerous occasions and
the ninth Circuit of appeals has ruled
in line with this argument that
legislation like this is
discriminatory and
unconstitutional and that violates Title
9 UM and there have been numerous amus
briefs coming from women's rights
organizations um from athlet Athletics
organizations medical experts and
coaches all arguing for transgender
equality and against these policies um
and I wanted to highlight with that that
when this legislation was introduced
and heard by the committee I think only
three or four years ago it was
unanimously voted down and so I would
hope that um looking at
the Discrimination that this bill would
allow that the committee would vote
align with it again and then just
speaking in terms of fairness and safety
a lot of these claims are
unsubstantiated if you look at records
for competitions there is no categorical
area where trans athletes have
continuously um won or have robbed uh
other athletes from Awards can you
please wrap it up for done the time yeah
thank you I'm open to taking questions
from the commit much are there questions
from the committee yes represent
cordelli uh thank you um so referencing
Title Nine is there a definition of sex
in Title
9 UM my understanding of title TI 9 is
that it has been interpreted by uh the
Department of Education to apply
to transgender people um that the sex
applies to transgender people in terms
of protecting them from discrimination
and the courts have interpreted it in
that
way yeah um you also mentioned a ninth
circuit ruling um of discrimination
could you supply us with that um ruling
I'd be happy to email the the briefs to
the committee thank you thank you
further questions from the committee see
thank you very much oh oh represent Bel
I didn't see you thank you Mr chair
thank you for your testimony I also
wanted to follow up on the on the
concept of Title Nine and and the
Supreme Court um you said that so title
N9 is is obviously it's part of the
Civil Rights Act Civil Rights Act has
been in place for very very many
decades so how come this is only just
recently within the last several years
years been seen as protecting cross um
cross biological sex within
Sports thank you representative for your
question um I think a lot of these
things have come up because we're seeing
more and more hostile laws against
transgender people trying to access
spaces equally in ways that we haven't
before um the ninth circuit decision I
had referenced comes out of a similar
prohibition on participation in sports
for transgender women out of
Idaho
um I
think a lot of these things have come up
because there's a lot of hostility that
has to be has to be challenged and I had
another point I wanted to make about
that but I am losing track of it so I I
will reach out to you after the hearing
thank you so much further questions if I
may just a further clarify on that point
point if if it's only just so recently
that all these laws are causing this to
be brought to the various courts and
it's only recently that this sort of
spirit has become upon us
um why were sex segregated Sports the
recently thank you for your question I
think you do highlight an important
thing that we need to work on as a
society which is the inclusion and
thoughtfulness of interex and
transgender people as it relates to
Athletics but um trans people have been
participating in sports for many years
and uh I wanted to note that I
think as far back as 2004 the Olympics
have had a policy and have had uh trans
athletes competing in sports and you can
date back a lot of policy and guidelines
like NCAA guidelines about what it means
to have uh competitive advantage and
fairness when it comes to to trans
participation and I don't think that
it's the place of the state to impose
this policing of of athletes in in the
form of this bill I think it's very
harmful and in the way that it works you
know uh looking at the like way in which
it's controlled through birth
certificate does this mean that any
masculine looking girl might be subject
to some sort of policing or might have
to provide her birth certificate for
investigation whereas uh you know
someone who looks more petite and
feminine what
not um you know I would like to see
these alleged records of danger and
violence in sports because as far as I
know I there is no substantiated account
of that happening thank you are there
any questions from the committee thank
Peters good afternoon chairman lad and
members of the judici education
committee my name is Christine Peters
and I'm the president of the New
Hampshire Federation of Republican women
I'm also been an educator in New
Hampshire for the last 25 years I'm
currently District chair of the SAU 39
school board and a mom of three
daughters and I have appreciated the
1972 Title 9 education amendments which
protected the rights and opportunities
of female students in educational
settings it was about Equity of
opportunity it was about safety and
wellness in 1972 everyone knew what this
meant that males were dominating the
playing field not just in sports and
that protection was warranted in recent
years this has become muddy we find
ourselves as a society undergoing mental
gymnastics attempting to define a woman
even the National Organization of Women
long a defender of women's rights has
left its original purpose of protection
from the website of the women's sports
Foundation the women's sports Foundation
supports the rights of all athletes
including transgender athletes to
participate in an athletic competition
that is fair Equitable and respectful to
all on the surface this is a reasonable
position and I am in no way advocating
that we ignore the natural rights of any
group of students however in a misguided
attempt to show respect to a
marginalized segment of the educational
population our women's sports programs
are rapidly becoming unfair to women
dismantling the equity of opportunity
and respect intended by the authors of
the 1972 Title 9 Amendments of even
greater concern is the safety threat
posed to Young athletes who are now
competing against athletes with a
natural biological advantage increasing
the potential for serious injury and
being required to share changing areas
with non-female athletes removing the
rights and opportunities entitled to
young women and jeopardizing their
safety and comfort in women's sports
does not achieve equity and I urge your
support of House Bill 1205 thank you
very much are there any questions from
the
gay
you may be familiar with this book well
would you please sit down
yes excuse
me um thank you um The Honorable Betty
gay I spent six years here and hope to
come back the reason that I'm here thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
testimony as a person who is not against
trans people and I highly recommend this
book which my chiropractor told me about
oh it's a family it's a family from New
England and they adopted twin boys and
as one of the CH as the children learned
to talk that's how young they were one
of them insisted he was a girl and he
was very unhappy to be a boy and this is
their story their struggle of that was
very painful but luckily has a pretty
good ending so I just want to say I'm
not anti-trends and I don't like any
kind of prejudice against anybody but
the reason I'm here supporting this bill
is that the best male athletes will
always beat the best women athletes and
it's only fair to keep a Level Playing
Field if Caitlyn Jenner who's one of the
most famous trans people trans athletes
although she doesn't compete now but she
says it's not fair and so I think we
need to pass a law that protects girls
and young women and women in competition
so that trans athletes can compete
against trans athletes and not against
girls and
women thank you very much and welcome
back thank you uh are there any
questions from the committee thank you
Briggs
hi and thank you for all your
contributions of your time to be here um
my other half and I um she's
by and uh so is much of my family and we
up until recently we used to go out to
all the bars the G bars uh I don't know
how what the term might be but anyway we
go to 313 the the Breezeway they're
wonderful folks wonderful and we both
agree on that and uh in any event we
really supported the LGBT community
until recently where you know they're
starting to uh advocating and a small
minority of course advocating for
butchering of kids under 18 and Men
reading stories to uh kids on their laps
well there's only one reason that for
doing that um and um schools making kids
question who they are um it's Dei divide
uh exclude and indoctrinate is is what's
happening these days and it's very sad
because the community as a whole is is
is really wonderful but it's it's
swinging this way and I think it's a
problem and most notably for men
destroying women's sports I don't care
what you call yourself still a
biological man with all the
advantages um and it's impacting women's
sports there's possibility for
scholarships to go to school woman loses
her right to go to school because she
can't get that scholarship that a guy's
GNA get who was Woman of the Year Dylan
what's his name mlan or whatever woman
of the year I mean come on this is
science we're talking about um I I can't
even believe that we're using all of
your valuable time to even discuss this
it's just a no-brainer with with science
um there's um it also um we're talking
about uh girls and women's privacy uh if
I had a a girl in sports and there's a
guy in there um I'm sorry we'd have a
serious problem okay wrap it up you're
going to be on your too okay U um and
women are getting physically hurt we
know that and also uh this would stop
women or girls who want to go in a sport
from participating because of their
parents or because they're afraid to
step up and do that because of this
women's records are destroyed the
Olympics is now I don't watch the
Olympics anymore because of compromising
that and women's sports I don't do it
anymore because it's all messed up
because your time is up yep okay thank
you very much are there any questions
from the committee thank you very much
brard Nancy Brennan from where she
her there's a new documentary called
will and Harper it's about the
friendship between actor Will frell and
writer Harper steel they go on a
CrossCountry road trip to explore her
new identity as a transgender woman
friends since they met on SNL frell
calls the trip a chance to transition
myself in a way to learn to get to know
my friend even more than I knew her
before to get to ask these questions
that I think a lot of sis people still
have the comments I've read in favor of
this bill calling transgender girls and
women boys and men are ignorant and
cruel they buy into the scare tactics
and stereotypes that further marginalize
an already vulnerable population here's
the thing about kids in sports I don't
know if you've ever seen any of the
surveys that they do but when they ask
the parents what's the most important
thing the parents say winning when they
ask the kids they say hanging out with
my friends there's a difference and
sports at this level are supposed to be
fun inclusive a chance to build skills
and friendships when kids aren't allowed
to play it hurts and for a transgender
kid it can be devastating in terms of
who expels it excels at sports there are
many variables some kids are natural
taller faster more coordinated there is
also an element of opportunity and
privilege for the kid who has a private
coach or whose parents can afford the
exclusive Sports Camps Dr Eric vain a
pediatrician and geneticist who has
studied sex differences in athletes for
many years says there are no good faith
reasons to limit transgender women's
participation in school sports The
Washington Post review of the
documentary will and Harper calls it a
movie that is so sweet and funny so
generous and gentle about your time is
up explaining
transness that it should go across the
country and teach people but you know
what we shouldn't have to have a child
or a best friend who is transgender to
have empathy and fight for in
inclusiveness Being Human should be
enough please it are there questions
scare welcome thank you good afternoon
chairman lad and honorable committee
members I've got a little bit of a
different concern and it's
transgenderism is a religious idea in
that it teaches that we are born with
these mutable gendered souls or gendered
identities and these gender identities
are our authentic selves not our bodies
they're less important than our bodies
but the safety issues that we've talked
about here today and fairness issues the
problem is that bodies compete not
gender
identities our current policies right
now are teaching young women that
they're second class citizens whose
needs are subordinate to male needs and
desires and it's wrong for the state to
use the force of laws to coer them to
sacrifice their rights to fairness
safety boundaries to validate men's
gender
identities now I often hear that most
girls are happy to compete against boys
and even if that's true the majority of
girls can't can't give away the other
girls individual rights to safety and
privacy moreover any girl that speaks
out of this about this and has spoken
out about it gets ostracized and accused
of
transphobia and one last thought if we
wait until a girl from New Hampshire
gets her teeth knocked out to address
this then we failed because we didn't
protect her so thank you thank you very
much are there any questions from the
committee not see you thank you very
Jacko
welcome my name is Lind Jake house I
live in do and I am a co-founder of 603
equality a community group dedicated to
creating a Granite State where all lgbtq
people can Thrive I'd like to read
excerpts from testimony provided by a
few people who could not be here today
and wrap up by adding a few of my own
thoughts but first I am here to say
unequivocally transg girls or girls
trans women or women biological boys and
men are not competing on girls and
women's teams furthermore the suggestion
that trans girls and women pose a danger
to the safety of other girls and women
is dangerous to the health and safety of
transgender girls and I would urge the
chair to ask any future testifier who
suggests that trans people are dangerous
to avoid those comments moving forward
those of you on this committee have
likely heard previously from Lane
Jocelyn a now 19-year-old transgender
woman who played High School soccer with
other other girls throughout high school
she says my closest friends played
soccer with me in middle school and
through high school no one had a problem
with me being transgender there were no
issues in the locker rooms or bathrooms
and I was treated just like everyone
else I guarantee that no one on the
opposing team has any idea that I am
transgender playing on a team is such a
unique experience with many life lessons
I enjoyed the friendships the school
spirit the giv and take necessary to
create successful plays the exercise
learning to handle the feed and be a
good sport in fact the support that I
received from my school when I explained
to them in fifth grade that I was
transgender was amazing my classmates
and teachers were instrumental in
helping me develop confidence and
self-esteem something that unfortunately
not all trans kids experience after I
came out I was treated like all the
other girls in every part of school in
the classroom in the art studio on the
theater stage and on the soccer field
there's no way I would have ever
competed on the boys team because I am a
girl now as a 19-year-old trans woman I
can fully appreciate all that Sports
provided me as a
student contrary to the imagined
testimony by a few testifiers previously
one of Lan's teammates Ellie said I had
the pleasure of having Lane on my team
during high school during the soccer
Seasons Lan was a fantastic teammate at
no point did I think she didn't deserve
a spot on the team or was out of place
she was where she should have been and I
wouldn't have had it any other way
another one of Lan's teammates it said
my good friend Johson was on my high
school soccer team for two years she was
always the first one ready to play and
the last to leave the field lean was
incredible to watch on the field and
hard to defend against not because she
was born male or because she had any
biological Advantage but because she
brought her all to every single practice
in game thank you thank you very much
are there any questions from the
committee yes representative Miler thank
you Mr chair and thank you for being
here you've heard many here today talk
about the physical concerns as far as
heart and safety how do you respond to
those comments they create an
environment in which young transgender
people particularly the girls and women
being targeted by this bill I'll feel
that their inherent nature is dangerous
to others they are told this in many
ways by many of the bills that have been
introduced trying to limit what they can
be a part of and it is as bad for their
mental health and for or inclusion in
all
spaces further questions representative
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
being here and taking my
question so I believe there's about
160,000 public school students in New
Hampshire and I'm not sure how many
students in other educational settings
but say 200,000 or so could you speak to
us about how many of those students are
trans students I don't know the exact
number of transgender students um
although I believe it's about 1% of the
adult population I think that is a
little bit higher in um or School aged
age children now because in many ways
acceptance has grown and more people are
more comfortable coming out at earlier
ages and being themselves um but when
you think about all trans children in
schools and then the percentage of them
that want to play sports and um there
that is a very
small handful of kids across as the
state that this bill takes particular
interest in and particularly targets
further question from the further
questions from the committee thank you
angeletta
welcome hello I just want to start off
by saying the world needs love and
equality more than anything right now
trench gender women are women and
transgender men are men in no way am I
discrediting the struggle battle or
Journey one with gender dysphoria has to
go through and the hardships that come
with that being who you truly are is a
beautiful thing that should be accepted
no matter who you are um this doesn't
change the fact that people who are
trans are in fact transgender things
like height build and strength don't
change unless done artificially and in
an effort not to bring down the trans
Community we are bringing down the women
who Train Day and Night for years to
compete in these Sports and we rob them
of recognition for their hard work when
we put them against people they don't
stand a chance with and they already
have to fight 10 times harder in this
world to be perceived as equal and the
other way around empowering men who are
beating down people in sports who don't
stand a
chance um is unfair to them as well on
how to place trans people in sports I'm
not too sure maybe placing people in
groups based on weight height and
fairness or maybe they're own category
not in effort to seg segregate but to be
fair for everyone including the trans
Community who also deserves it the world
is constantly adapting to change and we
just need to figure out how to change
the world to make things fair for all
and having unfair fights in sports is an
incorrect way of doing it thank you
thank you very much other questions from
you do you do you would you like to
submit that report or is it what your
your not oh uh sure do I just just it to
Smith hello committee members thank you
for taking my testimony um I am Jennifer
Smith I'm a retired Family Practice
physician I also am transgender if that
isn't obvious to you um and I was a bit
of an athlete at times and I still am I
still played ten in fact that's why I
was late my teammates don't seem to have
a problem and some of them are taller
and at least one of them hits a lot
harder than I do um so I just want to
talk to fairness for transgender girls
because in point of fact they will have
neither skeletal nor hormonal
advantages if they're competing and I'm
happy to take questions on this and I
have sent you the written testimony
through the online
portal um it's about a page and a half I
definitely won't read it but as anybody
can appreciate skeletal differences
occur and there is overlap between
Sexes and the problem of high levels of
testosterone does not exist for the
transgender girl who has started
transition before puberty and I can tell
you from my own experience of getting
rid of the unpleasantness of
testosterone that you definitely lose a
lot of muscle mass and speed and
strength I was still a distance runner
at the time that I got rid of that I
could tell my the times were dropping
fast I was a pretty good Sprinter at the
end of a race you know it's like no I'm
just not that
anymore I was always beaten by some of
the elite women in races even when I had
testosterone but the notion that the
vast majority of
transgender girls and women are somehow
putting other women at a disadvantage
just isn't really
true and um by the way I do use the
locker room at the Y and no one seems to
have a problem with that nor do I think
they
should and u i I'm happy to take any
questions and I hope some will read my
testimony I'm on my yellow card is my
phone number I'm afraid I didn't think
to put that in but I'm happy to talk in
detail to people yes there are cases at
Elite Sports level like possibly Leah
Thomas where there is an ongoing
Advantage from two much skeletal
development in a male
direction thank you that's difficult
issue any questions represent Miler
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here I'd like to have you talk a
little bit about the
transition that a trans person goes
through the impression that some have I
think is that if I want to if I want to
go from male to female I just start
wearing female
clothes could you talk a little bit from
a medical standpoint about what that
transition process is well things are
changing somewhat but when I
transitioned it took a full year of
living socially as a female to get
permission to move forward you often
were allowed to start taking some
hormones I'm a physician I had access to
hormones before I actually even talked
to a
counselor um so you know I I found that
yes and to speak to the spiritual side
of it that someone else mentioned yeah
it suddenly made sense all of those
struggles and I am a religious person
and I'm happy to discuss um the material
that's in Matthew 19 if somebody wants
to discuss that um because it helped me
figure out who I was um and uh there's
just a lot of
misinformation we're very careful about
this and every one of the young
transgender girls that I have known
through P
flag parents had to be puru persuaded by
their daughters to look into this and
find out about what this is about and
they would come to P FL trying to learn
and struggling with it and then find
that their daughters were suddenly no
longer these miserable little kids they
were happy they were doing well and they
continued to do well and putting up a
roadblock to their inclusion in school
sports makes no sense
whatsoever and you know if you want to
find a way to Advantage girls that's
great but please don't do that at the
expense of transgender girls they do not
have either skeletal or hormonal
advantages because they started out with
an X and A Y
chromosome it's just not true and by the
way there are cisgender that is not
transgender girls who have a hormonal
advantage I mean skeletal Advantage is
obvious but if you have polyic ovary
syndrome and that happens to be pretty
common your Androgen levels your
testosterone levels because all women
have testosterone if their ovaries are
functioning your testosterone level is
considerably higher and I did put a a
link in the end of my letter about where
you can find something that tells about
how much more common that high
testosterone level is in Elite women's
sports winners it's a just it is very
clear that testosterone makes a
difference but those transgender girls
who transition early aren't going to
have that advantage in fact they will be
at some
disadvantage from the blockage with the
hormone blockers and then with starting
estrogen at an appropriate age which
unfortunately there are other bills that
are trying to
prevent thank you very much are there
further questions from the committee
represent belon thank you Mr chair and
thank you for being here for your
testimony um you've testified that there
is no inherent advantage to a person
because of the uh cross- sex hormones or
any sort of medical procedures that they
were
undertaking however is it not true that
as of now anyway there there is no
requirement that a person begin
undergoing any sort of medical
procedures prior to identifying and
playing sports on on whatever team they
they would choose to be on I don't know
the answer to that and you might want to
craft something that does the kind of
protection that you think you want
without discriminating against
transgender girls who are not already
well into puberty because this bill
would in fact do that if it succeeds but
I would note that birth certificates are
amend in many states with no notation as
to the fact that they were amended and
you might also want to consider that
there are difficulties in figuring out
who is male and female at
times thank thank you very much further
questions representa Tanner thank you
and thank you for taking my question
you've obviously been in a number of
locker rooms and I was wondering if you
could explain the difference between
that you noticed between men's and
women's locker rooms and how more
private women's locker rooms generally
are yeah they're generally quite private
I've been in several because I do play
on a team that travels so um I I just
don't see an issue anywhere that I've
been and most women are quite private
although I have seen a couple of women
who didn't bother and were in a hurry
and just dis rubbed but you know as a
physician it doesn't exactly bother me
to see a woman naked so and I don't pay
attention thank you further
questions representative
Ford thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I'm intrigued a
bit by your discussion of the
developmental aspect of the transition
hormonally and so
forth how would you suggest that this be
addressed in the complexities of law
which tend to be either or or or you
know defined in concrete kinds of terms
I don't have a good suggestion cuz I
don't know that there is one but you
know the discouragement that people feel
at being othered is often enough to keep
someone who's say you know gone through
most of male puberty um it certainly
discouraged me at a point when I was
still playing pickup soccer because I
was a varsity soccer player um from even
thinking about whether I was going to
play seriously with other women other
than in a coed fun kind of way it's a
difficult question if you get into that
level and that's why I mentioned Leah
Thomas I'm not sure I have no idea Leah
Thomas is
a highlevel swimmer in the
NCAA um taking female hormones that have
reduced her
male hormones and perhaps at this point
she has no further ability to secrete
male hormones but yeah bigger hands
larger
[Music]
lungs lots of variation among women
swimmers anyway so is that something
that can easily be sorted out by the
NCAA I don't know and I think to ask our
high schools to sort this
out very difficult and I just don't
think that it is real that there are
going to be all kinds
of people who have gone through a lot of
male puberty trying to invade women's
sports just don't think so thank you uh
further questions from the committee not
sen you thank you very
much uh
Chrissy from
Manchester is it k a r t o r
k okay thank
welcome thank you for all your time I
appreciate it um a grandmother a mother
and oops sorry and an alderman in
Manchester and I'm really sad that we
even have to be here discussing this and
I believe that trans girls believe
they're trans girl they're girls but in
fact science says they're not and men
have penises and men have prostate
cancer prostates and I advocate for
prostate cancer all the time we are just
different and we It's Our obligation and
responsibility to protect girls rights
and their privacy and if we're not we're
violating their privacy and and their
rights and it's really really sad and
I'm just um a concerned citizen as well
and I have two daughters and two
granddaughters and I support this bill
and I hope you do as well thank you
thank you very much other there any
questions from the
committee thank you thank
Hawkins Sam Hawkins here yeah oh
good thank you chairman lad members of
the committee for the opportunity to
testify today my name is Sam Hawkins I'm
the public policy assistant at Nami New
Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness uh Nami New Hampshire is
a nonprofit Grassroots organization
whose mission is to improve the lives of
all people impacted by mental illness
and suicide on behalf of Nam I'm here
today speak in opposition to hb25 I'll
keep my testimony brief um nomin
Hampshire believes that freedom from
stigma and discrimination is crucial to
mental Wellness acceptance and support
within one's Community plays a key role
in the mental health of all people
including trans and non-binary youth
this is especially true for team sports
where students learn to connect with
their peers and their Community HB 1205
would limit access to these spaces
putting the mental health of trans and
non-binary youth at risk and then lastly
I just wanted to emphasize that
discriminator policies are damaging
whether or not they pass into law
according to the Trevor Project in 2023
quote nearly one in three lgbtq young
people said their mental health was poor
most of the time or always due to
anti-lgbtq policies and legislation it's
crucial that our policies promote mental
wellness and create accepting affirming
environments rather than limit them for
these reasons I urge the committee to
vote inexpedient to legislate for HP
1205 thank you thank you very much other
questions from the committee not see
thank you thank you uh Ronnie
Harding Ronnie she left
okay
Michelle Foy or fol
welcome okay just want to take a second
to say I'm very nervous and this is a
very emotional testimony for me so I'm
going to do my best to try and get
through as fast as I can I did try to
some thank you chair lad and honorary
committee members for listening to our
testimonies today my name is Michelle
Silo and I'm a resident of Temple I'm a
mother of six children and a physical
therapist I am here in opposition of
hb25 I grew up in Londoner from the
moment I moved into town I played Sports
one of my strongest memories as a young
Runner was a meet we had in sixth grade
it was a combined race with the male and
female athletes I came in second place
from that meet I went on to become the
record holder in the 400 meters the 600
MERS along with a long jump at
londondary high school during my career
I was the anchor leg for the state
championship team for the 4x4 relay
given a scholarship to nor Eastern
University to run track my career
continued there I go into this detail
with my athletic career not to receive
recognition but to emphasize that my
accomplishments were not once Lesson by
the runners I ran against they were only
approved upon the lessons I learned from
being an athlete were numerous as a
5-year-old soccer player I learned
teamwork and dedication
as an 18-year-old Runner I learned
self-discipline and drive receiving a
second place finish at the state meet my
senior year I learned humility and Grace
with my loss my time as an athlete
grounded my Foundation as an adult it
translated into my life through my
determination Drive empathy and
compassion that is empowered me to
successfully manage many obstacles in
life as a mother My Hope for all of my
children is that they will have the same
opportunities I was given in sports to
allow them to thrive and succeed in
their adult lives in March last year my
teen expressed they were experiencing
near constant Suicidal Thoughts
immediately we sought counseling for
them after beginning therapy they were
they were slowly able to talk more
openly to us about things in September
they came to me and asked if they were
too old to start hormone therapy after
that conversation a huge weight lifted
from our child's mind we are now
actively receiving care and are just
beginning hormone replacement therapy
also known as HRT to allow our child to
have a more feminine body they feel at
home in my career child has started
their own journey and I'm here to
support them we are incredibly fortunate
to continue to have our child here with
us today after their attempted suicide
in October I sat in a doctor's office
while at their side as they revealed
details of that attempt their attempt
was before they came to me about HRT
before they were able to express how
lost they were feeling in their own body
I come before you today to share this
very personal story to express my deep
concern for what this bill is attempting
to do HB 1205 escalates and exacerbates
the isolation trans youth like my child
have to endure supporting and promoting
the blatant discrimination of
transgender athletes is not the way of
the granite state sport should be a
place where we Embrace diversity and
teamm ship my child has been an athlete
since they were able to stand and kick a
ball they had planned to play soccer
their freshman year of high school very
Fort Unfortunately they broke their
wrist the first day of triy outs the
orthopedic cleared them to play on the
field but they insisted the only
position for them was
go I'll just finish off my last
paragraph the relationships a person
experiences through being a part of a
sport are life-changing though few
athletes reach the highest level of
competition the lessons received through
being a part of sport are immeasurable
to allow a person to be a part of the
sport they love is to not allow a person
to be a part of the sport they love is
cruel and inhumane please vote itl for
hb25 thank thank you very much other
questions represent
Damon thank you so very much for being
here and would you please share with
your
family that there is lots of support for
all people in New Hampshire are there
any questions for thank you thank you
very
Banfield good afternoon anray Banfield
um parental rights advocate in New
Hampshire um I will not repeat many of
the things that have been said
however uh I think that we can kind of
clearly see that a lot of times this
boils down to two sides you have females
who have feelings and you have trans um
students who have feelings and I think
sometimes it boils down to finding
common ground or finding a solution I
think the young lady in the back
mentioned something that I think we all
need to take into consideration which is
maybe a separate sports team for Trans
students these girls fight they
compete and then they have these
scholarships and awards taken away from
them we have to take that into
consideration we have to take into
consideration this the lock of rooms I
think that that's that's one thing that
we have to take into consideration there
are examples where males have even
portrayed themselves to be trans to gain
access to um rooms and been arrested
there's arrest records so my point is
there are feelings on both sides and I
do understand that and I think sometimes
we have to look at how do we solve this
this situation um also there was a a
reference to what the hormones do to a
body I would suggest checking the
British Journal of sports medicine that
suggests that trans women maintain an
athletic advantage over biological
females even one year after hormonal
therapy so there's a an independent
um I think I covered everything that I
wanted to cover you only gave me two
minutes so I'm going to take that and oh
you got 15 seconds left oh that's okay
it's all right okay thank you very much
other questions for
is
thank you chairman lad members of the
committee I'm here today on behalf of my
husband Chad trell and myself Amy
manzelli were residents of Pembrook New
Hampshire we respectfully request that
you vote itl on
1205 we wanted to share with you a bit
of our daughter's story iris is a
14-year-old vibrant trans girl it's
clear to us that our daughter has always
been a girl beginning at age three
essentially as soon as she could string
together a
sentence for Christmas she asked Santa
to turn her into a
girl eventually as she got older she
wanted to wear only girls
clothes which she told us by making a
skirt out of a blanket and begging to
wear it to
school then she wanted to use only the
female
pronoun which she told me one afternoon
when I was trying to be funny and using
my very very bad British accent and I
called her sir and she told me I should
call her
ma'am when she got old got old enough to
do Sports of course given that she is a
girl she wanted to be on the girls team
and she's been on girls teams and there
has never been any
issue over the years we've gone through
the legal processes so that all of her
documents reflect her female name in her
female gender marker she receives gender
confirming care with specific treatments
determined by her team of
interdisciplinary licensed providers and
her
family she's old enough now that she has
been out in the world as a trans girl
for over half her life our daughter
being a
girl is like the color of her skin or
her hey when she is an adult an
inescapable inherent
characteristic and if we could only just
leave it at that it could be
great but sometimes things are not great
it was not great when a peer tried to go
up her
skirt or when a different peer bullied
her for years so that she had to get a
safety plan and the school resource
officer had to be involved in the latest
incident
or when we had to tell her this weekend
her non-binary camp counselor just died
by
Suicide or now when for the fifth year
in a
row our family has to drop
everything and come to this state house
and this lob
again and beg you we beg you to
please preserve her basic human
rights so that we can remain in this
state in our home where we have lived
for 16 years now we are proud to live in
this state where you have recognized
repeatedly and protected our daughter's
rights as a transgender girl please
please do not erode this progress itl
1205 thank you thank you any questions
from the committee
bitman good afternoon third time today
all right I am uh speaking in support of
House Bill
1205 um I first would like to disclose
that I was the 1987 State doubles
champion in B badminton in Connecticut
um so I have been in competitive Sports
all of my life I was in gymnastics
swimming softball and basketball my mom
who was 77 years old was ecstatic when
Title 9 was passed because her
generation wasn't allowed to compete in
sports and that is why she afforded me
and my two siblings sisters to be able
to go and play in sports she was our
assistant coach and coach in many of
these
competitions I would also like to say
that when I was training to become the
state doubles champion in badman we had
three boys who decided they wanted to
join the team but they were not allowed
to compete but they were great to
practice with but I will tell you my
partner and I we could not ever beat
them even though we beat every other
team in the state because of their
physical and biological differences that
made them much better than us and we
could not beat them I would also like to
point out that the New Hampshire inter
Scholastic Athletic Association when
they have their policy on uh trans
participation is that someone who
changes because of biological that the
team um they're not allowed to um
participate on that team for not for the
purpose of gaining unfair advantage in
competition so the New Hampshire
Athletic Association already
acknowledges there is an unfair
advantage and that and one little story
about my daughters when they were
playing soccer um one of them I was 10
years old and their coach took the
entire team off the field because we
were at that time we were playing mixed
girls and boys and on the other team
there were two boys that were much more
advanced and we took and our coach took
them off for fear of safety and that was
at 10 years old and I will tell you that
children are enter ing puberty earlier
and earlier it is not 12 13 14 15
anymore it is 9 and 10 year olds thank
you thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee yes
represent
Woodcock thank you chairman just one
clarification my May uh when you're
talking about the uh two boys are
playing you in doubles competition and
your badminton yeah those weren't trans
girls those are no those are biological
boys biological boys F two biological
boys thank you so please you know it
perfect thanks yep okay thank you
further questions thank you very much
quickly my name is Irish Terell I'm an e
grader and a trans girl from Penbrook
this is who I am and nothing can change
who I really am I've lived in New
Hampshire my whole life and want to be
able to stay
here I have always known I was a girl
when I was 6 years old I finally told my
parents I am a girl I remember that week
I had a fight with my parents but but a
good kind came downstairs dressed in a
blanket that I had fashioned into a
skirt they wouldn't let me wear the the
wear that blanket to school no matter
how much I wanted to but they did ask me
if I wanted to
start to start wearing girls clothes and
I
felt finally happy that weekend we had
Target and started my new
wardrobe this made me very happy I even
won an award at the Deerfield fair for
my self-portrait I created myself of
myself with my very first dress with the
help of my very first art teacher
legally I'm a female I have a female
name I have a birth certificate with my
female name and gender marker I have a
court order that says I'm female and
orders my female and orders my female
name my passport says I'm female and has
my female name my insurance card says
I'm female and has my female name my
name is Iris and I'm female so when you
think about these
flws so when I think about these laws
you are considering I feel so disgusted
at Humanity's TR treatment um of
transgender youth meaning Humanity's
treatment of me for HB 125 what would
could this mean for me I could try to
play on girls teams I could try to use
the girls bathroom still try to use the
girls locker room because legal legally
I'm female but these proposed laws say
that me and my school could get sued for
having the trans girl in girls teams or
in girls bathrooms or in girls locker
rooms I probably won't use the girls
bathroom at school anymore because of
this who knows about sports I hope my
school has a good
lawyer thank you very much uh other
questions thank represent
whitcock yes welcome um how old are you
I am 14 thank you so much for being here
what a wonderful job thank you any
further questions thank you again uh
Robert
wilinsky
thank you Mr chairman and thank the
committee for hearing me I'll be
extremely
brief my name is Robert wonky and I'm
from Newberry New
Hampshire over 24 States half of the
United States has passed similar
legislation or undertaken similar action
to protect women in their
sports that protection is established
fairness in women's sports whereby bi
biological females only compete against
biological females and not against
biological males and can switch their
agenda for any particular sport it will
the proposed legislation before you was
comprehensive it was created using
similar language presented in the bills
that have already been passed and
adopted by other states
New Hampshire is the state of Live Free
or
Die I urge the members of this committee
to recommend order pass HB 1205 and I
thank you for your time thank you are
there any questions thank you K uh
Deborah
house
this okay good afternoon chairman lad
and members of the education committee
hope you can all hear me uh I'm Deborah
H I am president of the American
Federation of teachers New Hampshire I'm
here on behalf of our 3700 members
across the state and I'm here to speak
in opposition of HB 1205 related to
women's School sports and I just want to
make a couple of points aft proudly
support courts Public Schools where all
students feel safe welcome and that they
belong all students not just most
students but each and every single
student and for that reason we oppose
this bill for some students
participating in sports is where they
feel they most
belong um it's a place where they are
taught to work with a team a place where
they Forge peer relationships with
others their own age for most kids what
they remember from their childhood
Sports Experience is a lifelong
friendships they make
the
sportsmanship um learning the values
that being on a team can
teach so we do not want to deny that to
any
students in particular we do not want to
deny that to transgender
girls or any um group within our Public
Schools another question another point I
want to bring up is with this bill if it
passes it's unclear how it will be
enforced we don't keep birth
certificates as part of the hum files at
school and as we just heard from another
testifier those birth certificates um
can be legally
changed so how are we going to determine
what someone's biological sex
is they may not be out to their school
community and we also have a
constitutional protection for privacy do
you really want the school making
intrusive inquiries into someone's past
or medical
situation I really don't want to be
asking my members to be U making those
kind of inquiries about what someone's
biological sex is or what their uh
gender was at Birth so that they can
participate in a school activity for all
those reasons and mostly because all of
our students deserve to feel safe
welcomed in the belong in our Public
Schools we urge you to find HB 1205 and
expedient to legislate thank you are
there any questions from the committee
Hamill hi thank you chairman um my name
is Sally Hamill I support this bill
totally
um it's a matter of
physical um the boys are bigger and the
girls you know are competing against
them and you've heard from many people
of how their girls have gotten hurt um
and other things the women are leaving
Sports because they can't compete
against men and um I just want to say
that God does not make mistakes thank
thank you uh Sarah Robinson um Chris
urel from glad is finally I understand
that uh just
Sarah
thank thank you Mr chair the entirety of
the education committee for taking the
time to hear my testimony for the record
my name is Sarah Robinson I'm the
education Justice campaign director for
Granite State progress my organization
is vehemently opposed to this bill but
I'm sitting here before you to read
testimony on behalf of someone who is
unable to be here today when I uh I will
read their language verbatim so when I
refer to I or me that is what the indiv
individual has written to represent
themselves thank you for taking my
testimony and opposition to HB 1205
additionally 375 my name is Abby Maxwell
I live in conquer and I am representing
myself grown up each winter I had the
opportunity to be on a ski racing team
in a dark childhood it was my brightest
spot and I know that much of the
confidence that carried me to adulthood
was born directly from it now I have the
privilege of skiing with my daughter who
was eight when I started having to
testify against these kind of bills and
is now 11 we frequently ski while school
teams are practicing she asks about how
fast they go and then she asks if she'll
be able to race like that when she's
older I tell her that of course she will
knowing I will have to work so hard to
make my words true my daughter daughter
is a good has a good happy childhood but
she does not have an easy one in second
grade she was bullied for her gender so
much that the ACLU and glad had to step
in and our family had to move to keep
her safe she lives with the knowledge
that some people will not like her
because of who she is she knows that her
rights are never a given this is a lot
for an 8-year-old or 11-year-old or
anyone of any age to carry yet somehow
Against All Odds my daughter continues
to know that to be transgender is a rare
but wonderful thing yeah my husband and
I hold fast to all the areas where we
see her confidence grow we don't just
put money aside each year so she can ski
because it's fun we do it because we
know the statistics that result from
living in a culture that tells her from
so many angles that she is wrong
different and unworthy and that
something as simple as skiing could save
her life my daughter is a girl she will
not grow up to race with boys and to ask
her to is an act of bullying and
exclusion so before you vote I would
urge you to imagine what it might be
like to look into my daughter's eyes and
to to tell her that no in fact she will
not be allowed to race or play any sport
when she is older because adults in her
community believe there is something
dangerous about her if you did that you
would be forced to see how cruel this
bill is I urge you to oppose HB 1205
thank very much are there any questions
from the committee thank you thank you
low B
sorry um thank you chairman lad and the
rest of the educational
committee uh everyone has stole my
thunder uh but let me tell you where how
this all began and I'll be
brief uh back in July I asked our uh
Board of Education representative in
Newberry some questions with regard to
the sports teams she refused to answer
she sent me over to uh Mike
betet the assistant superintendent of
karge he and I have a stack of emails
back and forth like this in the end here
is the reason this bill is
here uh he told me in the end that they
may
discriminate gender identity point of
Excuse me yes what's your point I that
the last person that testified on Kar
Sports gave personal information that
the person identifiable and I don't want
that to happen again so could you urge
this person not to use terms about the
person to make that person did you hear
what she was saying not to use please
don't use anyone's name it's right okay
sorry
or Mr chair if I may bring a point of
order on my own I believe the public has
free speech and if a person is not
protected by law there is no prohibition
yep go ahead I'm just trying to tell you
how this got here and um I was told if I
wanted to change the law with regard to
the sports activities that are
happening at the school uh then we would
have to change the law at the state so
some of us got together we did a lot of
research looked at all the bills that
are passed in all the various other
states we put it together as we felt
best would represent New Hampshire and
uh Louise Andress was the one that took
up the sponsorship of the bill and we
moved forward so here we are but I I
have to say I participated in sports my
two daughters participated in sports my
two granddaughters participated in
sports I have a science and financial
background both educationally and
professionally I can compete with men
and I have been all my life but I'm
competing with this up here I don't have
to compete with this and girls right now
are competing against
trans women who have as other people
have mentioned are much bigger stronger
typically um so going forward uh in
following what other states have done
and what we can do here to solve this
problem is maybe as others have said
have
co-ed uh sports teams whatever but when
it comes to discrimination the few we
worried about it's the many the female
biological females who are being
discriminated against and it needs to
stop thank you very much other questions
from the committee thank
sey
good afternoon members of the committee
committee and chairman lad thank you for
having me and for hearing my testimony
today uh my name is Emma savini I'm the
children's Behavioral Health policy
coordinator at new Futures new Futures
is a nonpartisan nonprofit organization
that Advocates educates and collaborates
for the health and wellness of all
Granite saders um your future is here in
strong opposition to house bille 125
because transgender and nonbinary youth
deserve the same opportunities as their
peers to develop the social and
emotional skills that come from playing
sports um we all envision a New
Hampshire that is safe and welcoming for
our students and our children
unfortunately House Bill 125 threatens
this shared
Vision um we know that when transgender
youth are able to live their um lives as
their preferred gender um they have
mental health outcomes that are on par
with their
peers furthermore participation in
sports lends itself to development of
social skills such as leadership
teamwork self-respect discipline skills
that translate into successful lives
both professionally and
socially as such transgender students
deserve the right to participate in
sports develop these skills and have the
mental health outcomes uh the same
mental health outcomes as their peers
for those reasons Futures urges the
committee to vote itl on house bille
1205 and I'm happy to take any questions
thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee thank you
scare thanks I'm um I'm a mom I'm Beth
scar mom from NASA and I'm here to
testify and support of HB
1205 one thing I love about living in
New Hampshire is that as a woman if I
need help picking up something heavy or
reaching something up high I can count
on a man helping me it doesn't matter
his age or his political party New
Hampshire men are
chivalrous that makes it so much more
confusing and painful when I see male
legislators both Democrats and
Republicans who support allowing ma
males to compete in female
sports they know men are taller bigger
stronger they know males will dominate
in female sports they know
that male and female sports are
segregated because of the large
difference in size and strength they
know that if Sports competitions were
unisex that men would take virtually all
the trophies in
scholarships they know that women risk
Serious injury in contact sports like
soccer and
volleyball they know that males changing
in female locker rooms risks exposing
females to naked male bodies which is a
serious kind of sexual
abuse they all they know all of this and
yet they support allowing males to
compete in female sports these men have
joined the rush to affirm the totally
unscientific belief that males can
become females just by declaring they
are it's Madness and they know it they
will all be very sad a few years when
they look back at all the Carnage and
realize the serious harm that has been
inflicted on female sports the Lost
Awards the Lost scholarships the serious
physical injuries the sexual abuse do
these legislators think of their mothers
their sisters their daughters their
nieces when they vote on these bills
please vote ought to pass on hb1 1205 to
save women's sports thank you very much
are there any questions from the
committee thank
Brennan good afternoon thank you for
hearing me
today I am speaking in opposition to hb1
1205 I did want to mention that I played
uh basketball when I was in high school
and I've made much of my living as an
adult as a circus performer um beating
out boys for the strength roles I was
born with a bulba and I developed
breasts during um uh puberty so I'm a
cisgender woman going through menopause
so I'm losing some of that strength um
so I'm generally in opposition to laws
that uphold the extermin a of minorities
and uh this hb1 1205 is a bite into the
pursuit of happiness of trans kids uh
next to come will be another crunch into
the liberty of trans kids and adults and
the main course or the final solution
and yes I intentionally capitalize final
solution is a drooling snarling Chomp
that ends the lives of all trans people
in this state and the nation
people who can sit and listen to the
testimony of actual trans people and
stand on the side of this bill I really
question uh their taste in
judgment uh Ohio and other states
mentioned the 24 that have passed these
bills they follow them up uh moving on
to access to health care for kids moving
on to access for healthare for
adults then they move on to bathroom use
public bathrooms
employment and visibility in
public the safety issue here isn't
largely that someone's CIS daughter is
going to lose out to a trans girl in
sports statistically the data isn't
there and I have that here I'll give it
to you so you can check it out um and it
isn't that she's going to be ruined for
life by seeing a trans girl's penis in
the locker room in fact statistically
that won't be the first penis she sees
the safety issue is a straight and
narrow path to elimination of minorities
trans people queer people disabled
people Jewish people black people brown
people and a tightening definition of
what is acceptable as man woman and
human the slippery slope is toward a
future where everyone is looking over
their shoulder as they point at each
other trying to save themselves from
being masticated out of existence by
fascism minutes is up please see the
details of HB 396 going before the house
on Thursday to prove my point and please
oppose this Pro to trans kids Bill 1205
thank you thank you other questions from
the committee thank you very much uh
Chris
urel thank you chairman thank you
members of the committee uh my name is
Chris urel I'm an attorney at glad I
testified in this Committee Against uh
similar bills um many times and I'm here
to testify against this one as well uh
others have testified eloquently about
the important educational opportunities
the essential life skills that Sports
bring to a child's life which uh you
know uh communication teamwork
self-discipline leadership confidence
these are essential life skills that
should not be denied to any student and
uh fortunately federal and state law
protects every student's right to get
those skills and to every other equal
Educational Opportunity um I do want to
point out that it is an absolute myth
and it's an egregious and offensive myth
to suggest that transgender people are
unsafe when there is no evidence to
support that claim transgender people
are not unsafe and measures to improve
safety in school sports should be
prioritized excluding trans people does
nothing to further that goal I could go
into great detail talking about Title 9
and how it conflicts with this bill and
what this bill would do to New Hampshire
law um as many of you probably know in
2020 the US Supreme Court decided a case
BTO in which they said that uh sex
includes uh discri discrimination based
on sex includes discrimination based on
transgender status uh and Title Nine has
been interpreted by the federal
government to preclude discrimination
based on transgender status if New
Hampshire law and federal law are in
Conflict that's going to create a lot of
problem for New Hampshire schools and
for the Human Rights Commission I'm
happy to talk about that in more detail
including about the litigation uh that's
ongoing across the country in states
where similar bands have happened um I
want
to make a point that there are policy
experts who have made policies across uh
you know every Sports every aspect of
sports including the international
Olympics committee the NCAA every
professional sports organization and of
course the New Hampshire in Scholastic
Athletics Association that govern
fairness and sports and uh policy
experts have been involved in making
every single one of these determinations
it's not the legislator's role to get
involved um so there's uh there's
there's there's eight states where
litigation has been happening and I just
want to point out that in the majority
of those States courts have ruled that
banss on the participation in athletics
um for transgender youth are
unconstitutional and in violation of
Title 9 and uh I have more specific
details if anybody's interested in
hearing them thank you thank you very
much are there questions from committee
yes representa Tanner thank you and
thank you for taking my question um I
noticed that at the end of this bill
there's a Ser severability Clause uh
which I've seen every once in a while in
other bills and it always flags for me
that uh the people that wrote this
understand that parts of this bill are
unconstitutional and uh that they don't
want the whole bill to be down the trash
can because of unconstitutionality so
I'm wondering if you could just uh maybe
talk about a couple things in this bill
that are unconstitutional and give us
some specifics on the court cases yeah
absolutely um so the New Hampshire state
constitution in addition to the United
States Constitution both uh both uh
promise equal protection of the laws to
all people uh in the federal government
in the federal context that has been
interpreted by courts to mean that
people regardless of the regardless of
their uh inherent characteristics are
entitled to equal protection of the laws
which means they can't be faced
discrimination in the way that laws are
written same is true for um laws um in
New Hampshire uh and sex of course is
has long been considered a protected
classification under federal and state
law when it comes to interpreting the
protections and constitutions uh courts
have pretty uniformly agreed that
transgender people uh because the
because the difference between
transgender people and people who are
not transgender is a sex-based
difference that they're entitled to the
Protections in the Constitution um both
the state and federal Constitution and
so uh we've seen litigation in many
states and I actually I think it's
really interesting that two states in
particular uh Utah and Montana their
Sports bans have been overturned or held
to be unconstitutional based on the
state constitution as opposed to based
on the Federal Constitution so and and
so I just think it's really interesting
that uh courts around the country are
interpreting uh interpreting the way
that uh the equal protection analysis
works is to operate in support of trans
students ability to play sports and I
mean there's really good reason for that
there's absolutely no basis as we've
heard there's absolutely no basis for
saying that a 12-year-old transgender
girl who's never experienced male
puberty is has some some fairness or
safety advantage over over any other
girl there's absolutely no basis for
making that claim and so a law that
would preclude a 12-year-old transgender
girl who has never had male puberty from
participating with other girls is
clearly just targeted at excluding her
for for no other reason than because she
is transgender and so um building off of
that I mean again we have uh Sports
organizations that make policies that
that uh are are there to ensure fairness
and full participation to the maximum
extent which is a goal that all of us
should want and a law like this targets
transgender people puts them in a
different class and separates them and
says that regardless of what uh what
their bodies are like or regardless of
what uh they would bring to a team
they're still um excluded and and a
follow up on that please yes um have you
is there any law uh that youve heard of
that's like this only for um trans uh
boys I've never seen a any bill that's
been directed specifically at
transgender boys there are bills that
say transgender girls and transgender
boys can be are both going to be
excluded from playing on teams
consistent with their gender identity um
but yeah I mean there's actually an
interesting documentary so featuring
Sarah huckman who's a transgender girl
from New Hampshire but also featuring a
a young man named Mike bags who is a
transgender young man in Texas and when
he was in high school he was a wrestling
star right but because of the way Texas
law operated he wasn't allowed to play
uh um on the men's team and so he was
forced to wrestle against women and he
uh of course dominated the sport in a
way that was uh that was unfair to other
women who are participating and
um and all he wanted to do was wrestle
and all he wanted to do was play on the
boys team but the state wouldn't let him
and so I think uh that raises some
interesting questions about how a law
like this actually undermines the very
Norms that uh sex separation and sports
are intended to uh to to further so this
was a boy see follow follow because so
this was a boy that was taking
testosterone yeah it was a boy who was
taking test thank you very much
represent
Bel thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony um can you tell us what
federal court has ruled um in such a
manner against the law such as this in
accordance with title line yeah I mean
the most um the most notable case is the
ninth Circuit Court of Appeals which
upheld uh the determination of an Idaho
District Court Judge federal district
court judge ruling that um that the that
a sports ban was uh was in violation of
um um sorry in violation of the US
Constitution and uh you know also there
are other courts Arizona a Federal Court
ruled that it violates the US
Constitution in Title 9 like I said the
Utah and Montana courts were state
courts um Indiana there was a a
successful challenge in federal court
that ended up getting mooded because a
kid who has a plan of graduated so no
longer had standing so that um so uh in
West Virginia a judge blocked a case
temporarily from or blocked a similar
law temporarily from going into effect
um but that hasn't been that case hasn't
been concluded and it's up on appeal now
in the fourth circuit similarly um
there's a case that's in a bance in
Tennessee uh in federal court because of
um other cases that have been ongoing
and there's no ruling in that case and
if I may for clarification to follow up
on that um the highest court then that
is ruled on this is the ninth Circuit of
California um it's not the ninth Circuit
of California it's the ninth Circuit
Court of Appeals for the United States
of America right but it it covers
California and the Western District
mostly correct it covers this case arose
in Idaho okay but not being under the um
the ninth circuit and absent a
nationwide injunction am I correct that
a ruling out of the ninth circuit has no
legal effect in New Hampshire I wouldn't
say has no legal effect it uh you know
has persuasive effect on any any any
Circuit Court in the country uh that's
not to say that other courts might
disregard what the ninth circuit
determined and the first circuit has not
heard a case about whether or not uh
discrimination against trans people in
sports is a violation of Title 9 or a
violation of the US Constitution thank
you very much thank
Spencer hi thank you Mr chair for taking
my testimony um my name is Louise
Spencer I'm from conquer I'm also the
co-founder of the Kent Street Coalition
which is an all volunteer Grassroots
advocacy organiz gation with Statewide
membership um I hadn't planned to speak
but given what I see as the devastating
potential impact of this bill and the
harm that it can cause I want to make
sure that I am on the record and that
Ken Street Coalition is on the record
very publicly that we oppose this bill
um because of the harm it it can cause
and I would just state that um between
1913 in
1948 30 of 48 states enforced anti-
misation
laws that did not make those laws right
there is nothing about the fact that
there were 30 states that did that that
made that okay there is nothing right
about this proposed law it doesn't
matter how many other states have
similar laws New Hampshire has always
been a leader not a
follower up to now I've been very proud
of how our state has resisted this
direction that seems to have overtaken
the country I urge you to lead the way
and not follow and to lead with
compassion thank you so much thank you
are there any questions from the
committee thank you very much
and that concludes all the cards we up
here so we are closing the hearing now
for
about
that's